man I was I was glued to the speaker
vote all day and it was um you know it's
like one o'clock or something and the
House of Representatives they're coming
in and everybody's like we're gonna vote
and then the vote goes on Kevin McCarthy
loses and uh I laughed a hearty laugh
and then you know I'm seeing all of
these Republicans on Twitter being like
no all these conservatives and a lot of
them are my friends you know like you
know will Chamberlain's a good friend
but he's like this is ridiculous Kevin
McCarthy should win it's a waste of time
I'm just I'm loving it I'm watching it's
the Maga Revenge I mean it is I don't
know if Jim Jordan is the answer
let me give you a quick gist of it Kevin
McCarthy is the leader of the Republican
party in the house basically he could
not get enough votes to win speaker of
the house after three votes they adjourn
with no speaker it's a historical moment
it hasn't happened in over a hundred
years and before that it was the Civil
War so but I'd say it was a good day
because because as I'm sitting here and
I'm playing on the TV I'm at the TV
going and they're like roll call voting
and then I see only five votes were
needed to stop Kevin McCarthy for
winning I was playing OverWatch and I
got a 20 like I think I got like a 23
player kill streak with Diva oh you were
in the Flow State I was just I'm
listening to Kevin McCarthy lose and
like my eyes are glowing and I'm playing
as Diva and just it's a shooter Team
game and I'm just wiping everybody out
it was so much fun and then I I I was
just it was amazing like I killed like
seven guys and I'm just like missiles
Shields up uh it was a good day and I'm
and I'm just laughing and uh uh we got
we got to talk about it because this is
a historic moment hasn't happened since
1923 I think it took eight votes in 1923
so we're on three going under the fourth
vote three failures and uh so they
adjourn until tomorrow we'll see what
happens I think the McCarthy people are
only voting for him out of fear of the
Republican establishment they assume
he's the leader so they just say fine
whatever you say yo the Jim Jordan
faction the never Caverns at the very
least have conviction behind them that's
who you all should switch to vote for
that's it because look it's it's at the
end of the world it's just the people
voting for macarthy are just doing it
because they're told too that's not a
reason to vote for somebody so we're
going to talk about that we got other
big news
Jordan Peterson is it was was just he
just announced he was being he's being
forced to undergo some kind of like
social media sensitivity training or
they'll take away his license
so that's that that's that's a crazy
story and then we got to talk about uh
Demar and the bills
um man he's he's he's he's uh he's alive
that's good news last night we were on
the show people were mentioning he
collapses on the field and the the left
and everybody is saying is something
called like what is it called like
comedio cardio or carditis or something
I don't know basically they're saying
that he got hit in the heart at the
exact moment to cause a Like A
disruption which made his heart flow
improperly and then he lost you know
blood flow it's true it does happen but
there's a question I want to ask why are
so many people even the naysayers
immediately bringing up back vaccines
it's an important question whatever your
opinion on the matter is I tweeted this
morning a New York Post story it said
Cardiac Arrest 24 years old that's all I
said instantly some Lefty guy was like
it has nothing to do with the vaccines
and I'm like bro I I didn't bring that
up like I was like Wow Cardiac Arrest 24
is crazy I didn't say anything about it
but why are even the haters bring it up
there's an interesting conversation to
be had around that so we'll definitely
have that before we get started my
friends head over to nightwatchpro.com
and pick up your three inch large HD
display Crystal Clear Vision day or
night binoculars now I'm gonna say it
all right look these are a can it's a
camera it's got infrared it helps you
see at night it's from prepper's Peak
you get 60 off starting at 150 bucks 32
gigabyte SD card included these are not
these are not going to be military grade
night vision okay I don't want people to
think that's what this is it's just a a
binocular set that allows you to see
better at night and it's and it's
relatively cheap we've got uh I don't
think we have these exact ones we've
gotten similar ones to it but Luke and I
actually got the military grade it's
like fifteen thousand dollars for
military grade night vision if you're
not going to be getting that and you do
want to have something to help you see
at night check out Night Watch Pro it's
simple some people are you know uh
saying like well it's not like real
night vision well it helps you see at
night that's about it if you want to get
the fifteen thousand dollar one do it
but these are like 200 bucks you get 60
off so uh and you can record their
binoculars check it out
nightwatchpro.com
and uh it's got a rechargeable
lithium-ion battery lasts for several
hours they got a bunch of different
kinds sponsoring the show so special uh
shout outs to uh prepper's Peak at night
watch Pro for sponsoring the show and uh
take a look look into them and and see
if it's something that uh that will help
you it's got 36 megapixel HD photos
helps you see clearly in darkness it's
got four uh 4K recording so it's more
than just like some night vision it's
binoculars you can record with check
them out thanks for sponsoring the show
Night Watch Pro but also don't forget to
head over to timcast.com become a member
in order to support our work directly
the most exciting thing that I'm that I
want the one thing that I'm most excited
to talk about is the coffee shop that
we're building obviously freedomastan is
is is we're getting really close to
launching one of the problems we have
over there is we're waiting for internet
but the building is being done I post a
photo of it we're gonna have a skate
show launching we're gonna be doing a
Big Ten City Tour skate contest thing
I've got a bunch of plans we're going to
be building Community we're gonna be
building physical locations where people
can hang out become a member to get
access to our members only uncensored
shows but also just if you like the
stuff we're doing becoming a member
helps us do it so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining uh uh joining
us today to talk about this and so much
more is CJ Pearson thanks so much for
having me pleasure to be here absolutely
who are you good sir well uh who knows
these days uh you know I'm I'm living in
La I work for prageru having a great
time there
um doing all that we can to help beat
back all this crazy indoctrination that
we're seeing on canvases all throughout
the country I'm 20 years old I'm a free
thinker uh who is so excited to be here
so thanks for having me again right on
man well thanks for hanging out we got
Luke of course Los Angeles are you crazy
we'll talk about that in a little bit hi
guys my name is here we are change.org
and I wanted to remind everyone that if
you could question it it's science if
not it's propaganda I think a lot of
people need that reminder especially
today if you agree you could get this
shirt and you could remind them by
wearing it in a lot of public places
starting a lot of conversations and
meeting like-minded friends on
thebestpoliticalsharts.com because you
guys get the shirts that's why I'm here
thank you again so much for having me
science is the art of questioning thank
you for reminding me uh I also want to
say Demar Hamlin uh last night I said
that he got tackled correction Demar
leveled that dude tackled on the ground
nice job Demar and we're going to talk
more about you later in the show I'm Ian
Crossing let's get to it Serge what's
happening Brother hey what's up guys I
am search.com good to be here
um hope we have a good one Let's uh
let's jump right into it man all right
ladies and gentlemen maga's Revenge I
was excited to see it uh the house has
adjourned with no speaker
uh I I I dig it I do look man I'm not a
republican I've been saying this for the
past couple of weeks I don't care for
Kevin McCarthy in 2016 it was reported
that he apparently there's a recording
where he said Trump was being paid by
Putin or something like that okay Kevin
McCarthy said Donald Trump Bears
responsibility for January 6. things
like that this is a guy who is not
interested in the actual We the People
it's establishment garbage all the way
now look Marjorie Taylor green very much
wants him to win a lot of people have
said it's because she's got a quid pro
quo well yeah he's going to put her on
committees if he wins so she's like I
want him to win we're going to get
things done I don't see anything wrong
with that other than I'm not a
republican I'm not going to support
Kevin McCarthy so when he loses three
times in a historic failure I was just
laughing the whole time
um I I look I get it Jeffries is going
to be worse for a lot of reasons than
McCarthy here's how here's the fear
there's I think 434 people who are
voting because there's one vacancy you
have to get a majority of votes cast in
order to become the speaker that means
the only way the Democrats can win is if
Republicans vote Democrat maybe it's
possible the fear is if this drags out
too long Dem moderate Democrats and
Republicans establishment corporate you
know uniparty are going to be like can
we find 218 people to just put like Liz
Cheney as Speaker of the House and then
they'll do it there's enough people to
do it I'm not entirely convinced though
because I don't think someone like Liz
Cheney could actually pulled off but a
lot of people are basically saying if
Kevin McCarthy wins you'll get some
things you want if he doesn't win and
then there's some kind of uniparty shill
who who gets the vote spot because the
the Democrats and Republican uni party
will vote for him then we're worse off
I'm kind of like what's the difference
what's the difference between Liz chain
and Kevin McCarthy like don't come at me
with that I don't like the Republicans
okay there's a handful I like Thomas
Massey's cool Matt Gates and Lauren
bobert I think were awesome today they
stood up and said no but Liz Cheney
Michael Mouse had the sweet Liz Cheney
was the one who was uh introducing Kevin
McCarthy nominating him to be speaker
back in in 2021 so it's just like you
think I'm looking at Kevin McCarthy like
oh he's so much different from listing
yeah he's same thing same thing I don't
know if Jim Jordan's gonna be the right
guy either but I'm just sitting back
laughing that it's been 100 years since
a failure of this proportion hit and you
know what I think
The Establishment is so accustomed to
getting whatever they want that they are
that they don't know how to handle
something like this if it is only 20
people who have rejected Kevin McCarthy
so be it that is a good sign when the
Democrats were nominating Nancy Pelosi
and the squad threatened to withhold
their votes unless they got Universal
Health Care Provisions they caved
instantly and voted for Pelosi and now
what's happening is all the Democrats
are like see we're a unified party and
the Republicans are in disarray yeah
there was one person who tweeted that
the Republicans are so authoritarian
they that all of them now are fighting
because they demand they get their way
or else whereas Democrats are all about
democracy so they're in agreement and
I'm like oh okay dissenting is
authoritarian and marching in lockstep
with the corporate Democrats that's
that's not fast get out of here so I
don't know what do you guys think are
you happy to see uh McCarthy lose or is
just a big waste of our time I like the
way Matt Gates stood up and spoke about
it I actually have a tweet from Alx on
Twitter and you might be referencing it
in this article too with from the hilt
but he said basically like what Marjorie
Taylor green may have done is I want to
vote for McCarthy because he's going to
put me ahead of a committee but gays
like I don't want to be part of a puppet
committee well he said you can't drain
the swamp if you appoint an alligator
into a position of power which was a
pretty big statement okay said that uh
yeah Bravo oh and uh you know no
personally you know government gridlock
is uh is a part of my love language so
uh seeing what's happening right now is
pretty cool it's pretty awesome and it
shows you that you know the the
Republicans are aren't just the foot
soldiers aren't just obeying every
single order and they're willing to
stand up for larger ideas and principles
there was allegedly negotiations between
a lot of the dissenting individuals and
McCarthy McCarthy allegedly this is what
we're hearing from Lauren bobert and
other people didn't concede to any of
these larger demands MTG very
interestingly is coming out and saying
hey these guys are asking things
personally for themselves I'm not even
getting anything from all this so it's
interesting to see all this debate
personally I hope there's no speaker I
hope there's no Congress I hope there's
just deadlock I hope they're just
arguing and fighting each other all the
time so they leave us alone that's my
personal dream Gates said they
threatened to pull them off committees
unless they voted for McCarthy yeah
absolute Insanity you said it to me I'll
be like okay now I definitely won't what
do you think CJ if you're a congress
member who would you vote for you know
not anyone I'm in Europe but I think the
Silver Lining to all of this is that
literally until there is a speaker you
cannot swear in a single one of these
people so maybe we don't need a speaker
and maybe that means that the House of
Representatives cannot inflict any
further damage upon any people who
actually value limited government in
this country
um you know and it's a shame to see that
like literally if you are an everyday
American and you fail to do a basic duty
of your job you are fired these people
cannot even elect a speaker of the house
it's absurd yeah I say fetterman for
speaker I mean why not let's make this
happen and also it doesn't have to be a
congress member it could be anybody
trying to become speakers
you name it let's put him in there but
mix it up change it up a little bit I'm
sick of these politicians and plutocrats
and people who don't give a damn about
us let's totally change it up but let's
get let's get Ronald McDonald in there
he'll do a better job than all of them
seriously the the prediction Market's
been pretty wild Kevin McCarthy is
currently leading on predicted followed
by Steve scalise then Jim Jordan Jim
Jordan's dropped down he's at 12 cents
earlier but Kevin McCarthy actually got
knocked out of the top spot for Steve
scalise it's been bouncing up and down
nobody knows right you you want to talk
about wisdom of the crowd most people on
predicted right now they're leaning
towards it's probably going to be Kevin
McCarthy that's why it's 45 cents per
share he's the lead but it's been
bouncing some people think Steve scalise
will be because he's in a leadership
position he will be the compromise and
I'm just kind of like
yo the first vote happens in the house
and you need only five defectors to
block McCarthy and they vote for like
Biggs and there were a few a few other
votes like you know just random people
well I should say random people but you
know a person will get like one vote
then you get Matt Gates nominating Jim
Jordan
Jim Jordan nominating Kevin McCarthy
then it goes to a vote again and this
time Jim Jordan gets 19 votes so ever
like the the never you know McCarthy
faction unifies then it goes to the
third vote
you know the third vote Jim John got 20
votes it actually went McCarthy went
down yeah Byron Donald's flipped his
vote right exactly Jordan good this this
I'll tell you what exactly what I saw
people like why is Marjorie Taylor green
supporting Kevin McCarthy because she
wants to be on committees she doesn't
have the power to go up against the
establishment the best position she
could get is you get Kevin in she gets
on committees she can actually do
something
but
I don't think it'll be enough I think
what they'll do is McCarthy will get
them in committees where they'll have
just enough power but not really enough
to do anything you get Jim Jordan maybe
you'll get something a little bit better
I'm not even convinced Jim Jordan's
gonna be the right guy he even won he
doesn't even want the job but anyway but
Kevin McCarthy already moved into the
speaker of the house office
if it's gonna happen I mean it's
politics Anything Could Happen they
could bring out the the FBI and CIA and
the Epstein tapes and that could be uh
all voting in unison right away so so
that could also happen or they could
bring up the internet history that they
have on them or are there private
information and data that they have on
them but MTG made also some very
interesting comments that I think are
worth considering and talking about she
was saying we need to vote for Kevin
McCarthy because the Republicans could
actually get rid of the 87 000 IRS
agents that are supposed to be uh
inducted into the IRS that's her kind of
explanation to it but again I I
personally love the the fighting myself
yeah I'm shaking my head so hard over
here it's not gonna happen it's not
gonna you you put Kevin McCarthy in a
speaker and he's going to be like well
hold on we got to play by the rules
there's a way to do this oh come on
spare me dude I'm the guy who claims
Trump was being paid by Putin the
Republican look Republicans teamed up
with Democrats to stop Trump to stop
Margaret to stop America first I'm not
interested I just don't care I am
actually turned on by humility and the
fact that this Jim Jordan guy who I
don't know doesn't want the position and
he's willing to nominate someone else
but they still want him for the role I
think he's the right guy contrary to
what Kevin McCarthy's been saying it's
my turn I earned it if you don't give
this to me you're embarrassing the party
and the nation it's like that type of
entitlement is the last thing we need in
leadership in Washington today so it's
like yeah I'm right there with you we
need humility we need someone who
doesn't want it at all yeah but Jim
doesn't want it because he wants to be a
part of committee's uh and exactly and
wants to investigate allegedly the FBI
and the intelligence agencies allegedly
would he be like neutered his ability if
he were to become that the speaker yes
and then we also talked to Lauren bobert
just a couple days ago so specifically I
had a conversation with her and I asked
her hey we need a new church commission
style hearing I was like what's what's
the chances of that happening uh if you
guys don't know what the church
commission hearings are it's where all
the dirt about the intelligence agencies
in the 70s was revealed it was the heart
attack gun it was the infiltration of
the corporate media it was incredible
incredibly important hearings that
actually had a little bit of
accountability when it came to the
intelligence agencies I was like what's
the possibilities what substantias and
she was like not that good so I mean
allegedly she's negotiating with Kevin
McCarthy trying to get something done
here is that a part of the negotiations
I personally hope so we'll see look
bobert said they're working on it that's
something they do want but look at how
many you get 20 people to defy The
Establishment good I'll take it but I
just you get these these these
establishment people in all of this is
gone investigation of Joe Biden I doubt
will happen and if it does it'll be so
weak and pathetic it will be end up
being nothing it will be okay yeah we'll
do the investigation and then they're
gonna go find some homeless guy and be
like see what you can find and they're
gonna come 10 bucks yeah sometimes it's
worse to do a shell of an investigation
than no investigation because they'll
try and put it to rest with the normies
when in fact they haven't actually done
anything I've done a single yeah that's
that's a 20 right there Ian rolled a
straight 20. I think that nist did that
with the 911 uh World Trade Center I
mean that thing that commission had
holes all through it if you want to look
at that yeah they they will do an
investigation and they'll ignore 99 of
of you know Joe Biden and his family
they'll focus on little tiny things here
then claim it's debunked and say look we
did your investigation and it was
debunked that that's why I'm like nah
not these guys
Select Committee sorry go ahead yeah now
look at the Benghazi select committee
like what actually came of that nothing
of substance you didn't see any people
go to jail you didn't see anyone
actually be really investigated maybe
it's time we actually learned from the
left at least the j6 committee whether
or not you like it or not um and it was
absolutely disgusting in the way in
which they weaponized the federal
government against people who disagree
with their beliefs but maybe that's what
we should be doing in terms of looking
into how the federal government has
actually been weaponized against
conservatives throughout this country
we're seeing it also in the Twitter
files someone someone chatted if
Jeffries wins there will be no there'll
be no investigation at all I'm like yeah
that's actually uh the point Ian was
making that's better if there's no
investigation we can eventually get one
if they do a sham investigation they'll
be like we already did your
investigation we found nothing you're
wasting our time and then with the
normies they're gonna be like oh that
was debunked wasn't it yeah so it's
almost better to have no investigation
than a fake one with someone like Kevin
McCarthy Republicans when who are
actually Democrats driving uh driving
the speed limit or Republicans are is
that the same am I getting it right
uh um wait yeah Republicans Or democrats
driving the speed limit oh yeah yeah
that's right yeah so you know that
that's gonna be a no for me dog
yeah here let me pull this up let's talk
about the history so uh I have this here
from Wikipedia the list of speakers 1923
check this out
Progressive Republicans had refused to
support Gillette for the first eight
ballots only after winning concessions
from Republican conference leaders uh a
seat in the house rules committee and a
pledge that requested house rules change
would be considered did they agree to
support him this was the first
speakership election to take multiple
bouts since the Civil War and then we
have this from The Washington Post check
this out
when the house needed two months and 133
votes to elect a speaker
okay
they say you know goes back to 1856 it
was a crazy election took months
let's let's hope that we resolve this
house stuff tomorrow
because if it ends up taking eight votes
and then finally there's concessions
made and maybe Kevin McCarthy gives more
concessions to say Matt Gates loan
bobert et cetera enough that they
actually will be able to do real
investigations or something like that
it's better than taking two months and
uh being more indicative of a coming
civil war or something you know what
would be a scenario if there was no
speaker
well there would be no new member sworn
in you wouldn't be able to vote on
anything else until there's a speaker in
office so it would literally put the
entire Branch
um at a standstill rather than the
Senate they were sworn in today but so
they couldn't even vote on things if
there's no speaker I like that idea that
sounds great that sounds awesome and you
only need five people yeah five people
man shut down Congress let's do it yeah
how did but how did Thomas Massey vote
did he vote for McCarthy
sure
let's pull up I I I wonder I'm not sure
if he was one of the defectors or not I
don't think some people people were
telling me not to call the voters
defectors the people voting for Jim
Jordan are the people's vote and the
rest are the shill votes I want to
stress this all right
the people who are voting before
McCarthy are just doing it because
McCarthy's The Machine he's the
Republican machine and when the machine
comes to you and they control funds and
they can Crush you they say look you
vote for me we'll get you the Committees
you want that's the way it's played
don't f with me and they go yeah yeah
for sure no problem now you've got
people who are like I don't care
Matt Gates is like I don't care I'm not
going to vote for it's not gonna happen
Lauren Barber says the same thing this
is the I am a Spartacus moment this is
where people the Republicans can now
stand up safely and say look I don't
want to cause any problems but you guys
don't have it I'm gonna vote for Jim
Jordan yeah they need to do it yeah
and it's that type of moral courage and
conviction that we need right now if
we're actually going to have the
investigations that really matter like
you said looking into all this fouchy
related stuff looking into the Twitter
files and big Tech collusion with the
federal government we don't do that by
having someone who has already showed us
who they are like literally believe
someone the first time when they show
you who they are when is McCarthy in his
history as you know a member of
leadership ever really been the guy to
you know burn down the barn and say
we're going to get to the bottom of this
and figure out what exactly is going on
um Jim Jordan has showed us who he is
um you know there are other options out
there who have shown us who they are and
I think that like when you have those
options especially when the fact that we
don't control the Senate and the
Democrats and the left will still
control the White House for several
years to come so it's like we are the
opposition party all we can really do is
investigate and hold people accountable
and if we don't have a speaker as able
and willing to do that then what are we
even doing what are we wasting our time
on what I also just like the Revenge
element of it yeah like it was just
funny to watch Kevin McCarthy lose three
times in historical failure because he's
he's been a never Trumper he's been he's
look man they're a handful I'm not a
republican I keep saying a million times
never cared for the Republican party but
then all of a sudden and I was even late
to the party too like I I they were they
were former Occupy Wall Street people
nine million Obama voters switched to
vote for Trump and I was like I'm not
voting for Trump then I start seeing
what Trump is doing I see these people
who used to be Bernie supporters now
voting for Trump and I was like wow like
I didn't even realize that and then
people were like look he wants to bring
jobs back to this country he wants to
secure our border he wants to end
Foreign Wars and I'm like you know those
are really good points like I didn't
take Trump seriously in in the beginning
I probably should have should I probably
should have at least you know but I was
just so jaded so this time around okay
I'm gonna vote for the guy
does Kevin McCarthy and and you know
even with all due respect Marjorie
Taylor green think that someone like me
would actually get behind a guy who
claimed Putin was you know that you know
the Russia he pushed the Russia
collusion nonsense or the January 6th
nonsense I'm not interested in that yeah
that that's you you will never see me be
like a proud party Republican who's
gonna March in lockstep with Republican
establishment because I'm supposed to
not interested in that according to
oxios Thomas Macy is voting for Kevin
McCarthy yeah that's what I figured I
figured uh I'd like to see Massey a
speaker of the house that'd be great
he'd probably just like could you
imagine if Ron Paul was speaker
just I'm not gonna swear anybody in yeah
we're just we're just just did a real
job a young man honestly stopped Thomas
Massey would be a great speaker of the
house because he's kind of like a robot
I mean I love you Tom obviously with
like uh like autistic robot you know you
got the engineering skills down if you
know what I'm saying man we need someone
that's that's impartial that's willing
to just work off of facts and logic if
they're gonna function as a as the
speaker for the whole you don't want the
emotions clouding it up here's you're
not a robot bro you're a man let's let's
let's let's go back to the core of this
this segment right so it was 1856 just
before the Civil War when tensions are
as hot as it ever been and it took
months to finally get a speaker then of
course a few months a few years later
they're in Civil War then you get 1923.
so I suppose my view is I know Luke
you're saying gridlock is good and I'm
like yes gridlock's preferable to
corruption but I want a net positive I
want investigations so I guess my
concern is
what's what's the what's the risk of
destabilization if we go for hard
investigations and accountability versus
letting the machine lock itself down and
then just having nothing happen right
like which is what is the preferable
scenario yeah you could accidentally
uncover a lot of stuff that makes people
very angry very riotous and then you
have foreign corporations come in be
like you're the victim here the American
government was out to get you we'll
protect you I'm Klaus Schwab I'm here to
help and uh then all of a sudden we have
a corporate State the foreign
corporations have already taken over the
public government in they already they
already are in charge they already are
crawling the shot so we look at our form
of government They don't serve the
people there there's been many studies
particularly showing populist the
policies never get passed the lot of the
policies that the lobbyists want past
they get passed especially when they
have big money behind them so that that
what you're warning about happening
already has happened well so but look my
question for you is do you think it's
better to have investigations like a
church commission or gridlock shutting
the government down investing
allegations or whitewashes that's
another no I know let's let's say we
could get let's say Jim Jordan wins and
he actually says okay we're gonna have
some accountability maybe not perfect
but it's going to be it's not gonna be a
white wash so is that is that good or
would you rather see gridlock I'd rather
see gridlock because it's going to be
the same government that just a couple
days ago passed the 1.7 trillion dollar
spending bill it's going to be the same
government that just passed Bill Gates's
inflation reduction act which doesn't
really uh reduce or do anything with
inflation it's the same people
predominantly in power right now that
are going to be doing more with your
life and I just have I just I just don't
believe them when they're going to come
here and say we're going to do things
differently now I mean really come on I
agree like that's the thing too like a
lot of people are saying Jim Jordan and
I'm kind of you know I I guess maybe I
mean I've seen it I've seen him write a
lot of letters I've seen him speak up a
whole lot it's better than nothing but I
don't know if I've seen enough to where
I'm like you he's the guy like Thomas
Massey is someone where I I trust him
that if he was speaker you you'd
actually see something happen I don't
know about Jim Jordan that's why I
probably agree with you more Luke my my
view is your option the options and the
speaker vote today were control or
controlled opposition that's why I'm
just like not interested yeah what's
your what's your vision I think that's a
lot of people right now but I think when
you talk about is it worth the trouble I
think the people want the trouble they
want to see these investigations they
want to see these these truths uncovered
wherever that may lead and I think that
it's so easy to get trout of the
personality debate when it comes to this
because we're dealing with people do you
really like McCarthy do you really like
Jim Jordan those are all personality
questions but I think at the end of the
day what we are seeing from if you just
look at Twitter and the conversation
that's going on about it every single
tweet that Marjorie dealer green has
made
um you know super Manning for Kevin
McCarthy has been ratioed every single
oh yeah and it's just like the people
want accountability and we're not going
to get that by being the complacent
conservative movement that we've always
been I was I was watching War Room
earlier and marger Taylor green appeared
on it and so I'm like I got to see this
because you know look I like Marjorie
and I want to I want to hear what she
has to say about Kevin McCarthy and yo
the chat lit up with shell sell out
you've turned you've abandoned us
backstabber they are not happy with
Margaret Taylor green on this one it's
worth hearing her out of course before
you start judging the person she's not
wrong in the sense that she has a logic
to her decision Kevin McCarthy is the
leadership he's made concessions on
certain things he said there will be
investigations and she's probably been
guaranteed committee positions where she
who I trust would actually do something
will do something
but I'm just going to come out and say
it like
Marjorie is a republican she's a trump
Republican but she's still going to be
there for the party don't look at me
like I was barely there I wasn't there
at all in 2016 I was barely there in
2020. and I think that's the problem
Republicans barely squeaked by because
they were able to convince a lot of
post-liberals moderates and you know
like like more middle of the road people
to support them now they're coming out
and saying it's it's here's how I feel I
don't want to speak for anybody else I
feel like now that they've won they're
coming to people like me and being like
okay now that you've helped us fall in
line here's our Republican establishment
plan I'm like bro don't look at me
you're not going to convince me to I
think you're lucky you got my vote in
the first place yeah so I just I just I
don't see it man you should always be
reticent about voting for quote the
party that's a big Hitler attack you
know Hitler wrote about the party in
mineconf it's all about the party
putting the party first you know it's do
not do that in America I mean oh geez
you know here's you know here's what we
need we need an Elon Musk in Congress
and I don't mean Elon Musk literally I
mean someone who's willing to stake 40
billion dollars to do something kind of
Off the Wall kind of nuts I would like
to see Matt Gates stand up and nominate
Donald Trump he should he should get up
there he should be like I am nominating
Donald Trump for Speaker of the House
he is a great leader he has massive uh
you know support along the base there
you go but could Donald Trump even get
the votes at this point right who cares
that's the thing like someone needs to
throw a figurative pie yeah like Jim
Jordan is not a pie Jim Jordan is a
middle finger to McCarthy so he can't
win but come on like Biggs was was not
bad you know Freedom caucus guy but they
they could they could have still done
better you know I mean even even even
Matt Gates nominating Lauren bobert
would have been better yeah okay you
know whatever who should it be luke uh
Ron Paul
doctor no they called him that in the
Congress because he would vote no on
everything see like we need that kind of
leadership so here's a question like why
doesn't Thomas Massey do it maybe
because he's more robotic and he's more
like you know it's not worth it because
no one nominated him is that the only
reason yeah if I was if I was in
Congress it would be it would be I'd be
the craziest person in Congress people
would be like this dude's out of his
mind I'd stand up and I'd say Ron Paul
you'd be the AOC of the right no yeah
you would no AOC fine line fell in line
behind Nancy Pelosi she got whip crack
and she was like whatever you say Pelosi
what do you think
Ron Paul and I'll be like look I don't
agree with Ron Paul a lot of things he's
you know he's a right libertarian kind
of guy but I agree with him on one thing
he promised to leave me alone if the
government has a guy in there who's like
here's my policy positions I'll go okay
I don't like all those but I also
promise first and foremost to leave you
alone I'll be accountable for you yeah
so I if I was me I just I I'd throw a
figurative pie I'd be like can we
nominate Thomas Massey there's 45
000 people listening right now you guys
want to nominate Massey let's do it
Thomas you got my nomination yeah but I
think the thing that like makes him not
want it is also a part of his virtue
like Thomas he just wants to go up there
fight for America fight for a limited
government he's not at all really
concerned about the power and that is
just oftentimes like the conflict of
politics that everyone that we want to
run never runs because they're smart
enough to know not to and I think that
like why would you actually want to be
Speaker of the House sure you could do a
lot of good work but like why would you
put yourself in that position
um can we get Michael someone someone
said Michael Mouse for a speaker Andre
Super Chat I'm like how about we just
can he run for Congress uh yeah you know
just yes
you know him just being in there would
be hilarious let's break down I think
someone like Jeffrey Dahmer would be
more of a perfect fan in Congress when
you look at his activities they match up
with what Congress is doing you know
that pretty well as a member of the
black media I don't know if I can
endorse that I'd be safe for us
um you know no but but hold on there on
that thought
there have been I've heard people talk
about
sending like like having people like
Dahmer murderers people with Criminal
Intent into the military into foreign
conflict uh intentionally they look for
these people because they want combat
yeah imagine if if you took all the
serial killers in the United States
instead of imprisoning them we're like
we're gonna unleash you on our enemies
that's like Starcraft is how they do
yeah blizzard they put guys inside of
Mech suits permanently forever as that's
their prison and then they have to fight
in the Mexicans that's taikus he's one
of them
well okay yeah I don't know they could
always turn on their turn on their
captors what's our resolution to this
historic moment what do you guys think
before we move on well what's the
speaker of the house what's the purpose
of the role it's it's third in line for
the presidency all right they're they
basically are the highest position in
Congress in in the house and so they set
committees they they decide when bills
go to the floor things like that is it
they the one person sets every committee
I I don't know exactly through the house
during committee but the speaker
basically controls his appointment so by
extension the speaker yeah it makes
sense can the speaker overrule the point
committee is that what's called they can
they can change the rules of the session
of the Congress it's a very powerful
position in government yeah someone joke
someone joked that um the the the
concession for like Matt Gates and
bobert and all them they should tell
Kevin McCarthy new rule for the for for
the 118th Congress that Democrats don't
get to vote
you could make any like you could make
up weird rules I don't know how weird
you can get but uh like Papa John's for
dinner on Thursdays they could do that
kind of stuff I mean that'd be that'd be
cool I would just I'd love to I'm
thinking about it and I'm like man
I wish I could be there I I would never
want to be in politics it's awful but
just for that one moment to stand up and
nominate Donald Trump would be totally
worth it or nominate someone like Dave
Smith wouldn't that be just amazing if
somebody just got up and said Dave Smith
he's a funny guy libertarian let's have
him do it
that'd be great yeah just just to say it
so on everyone everyone watching on
C-Span or whatever here's you say it the
most interesting thing on season in a
while all right so this is gonna happen
tomorrow they're coming back at noon
there's probably another vote
right now I bet every single one of
these people they're on the phone
non-stop you've got threats probably and
threats aren't going to work you know
Matt Gates came out and said they
threatened to take away our committee
positions don't care you're not gonna
you're not gonna win this one against
Matt Gates by going in there and
spitting on him and threatening him
you've gotta you're not gonna get it
unless you unless you give a little bit
and where was this energy towards Elon
Omar right what everything that she said
that was anti-semitic and all of these
things they have done more to criticize
internal dissent even going the length
of saying we're gonna take your
committee away but where was this energy
towards Elan Omar Rasheeda Talib it's
like insane it's like they want to crack
the whip on our own side but yet we can
never focus on the common enemy and hold
the left to the same account that we're
trying to do to ourselves because people
like McCarthy keep winning there's three
and it's because so many of these
Republicans are scared to go up against
the Republican establishment because of
things like what happened to Blake
Masters it's there's three parties in
Congress right now it's Democrat
Republican in this new party that's
still Republican Maga yeah whatever you
want Maga whatever the lion got
energized Trump elephant donkey lion
yeah there really is and I think that's
where all this divisiveness is coming
from is the two political parties within
the Republican party which for whatever
reason they haven't started a new party
yet well you know what um um we'll see
what happens I'm I'm I'm tired of the
same old same old so I'm not interested
in voting for these people just so that
they can come look
Donald Trump is what convinces me and
and Maga and all that stuff to vote for
it they oppose the The Grooming of the
kids stuff the CRT Foreign Wars stronger
borders all that like they support
stronger borders I'm for those things I
am not for 14-year establishment
Republicans who are Democrats go on the
speed limit I just I'm not for that
let's move on to this next story though
because otherwise we'll go in circles
take a look at this one from Yahoo
sports
Demar Hamlin has cardiac arrest on the
field NFL suspends game versus the
Bengals you may have seen this but what
you may not have seen is I will play you
this clip from CNN of Sanjay Gupta let's
see will the uh is the audio gonna play
throughout the body there we goal is to
restart the heart and it sounds like
that they were able to do that on the
field most likely with a defibrillator
applying electricity to the heart to
restart that and then also we learn from
Adrian I believe she said earlier that
he continues to be in critical condition
which we knew but stabilized overnight
which is obviously important so hoping
for updates what I've just described is
a rare situation again I I had actually
never seen it happen certainly not you
know a film the way that it was you know
for for frankly the world to see but
that seems like the most corruptive okay
Sanjay Gupta says I've never seen it
either he is a terrible doctor
or something really messed up is going
on now I I okay I know guys guys he
could be both all right it could be both
he's a terrible doctor and something bad
is happening I get it I get it everybody
else I said that I was like either it's
a terrible doctor or something mess Up's
happening but let me point this out he
said I've never seen this last night on
the football field uh Damar he he's got
the guy you know I don't know who the
other guy was running at him I'm not a
big football guy he tackles them they
spin hit the ground he stands up then he
passes out
so you want to look up what people are
calling it like committee oh yeah I got
that it's commercial Cordis commercial
quartus okay Latin for agitation of the
heart okay so they're arguing it's this
rare thing where your heart gets hit
right at the right moment causing some
kind of fibrillation which disrupts your
heart or whatever
Sanjay Gupta on CNN said I've never seen
it before
really you've never seen it before take
a loose
here this is um
airtable.com this was posted on Twitter
by died suddenly I am not making any
assertions as to what's causing any of
this nor does this table but homeboy
Gupta wants to go on TV and say I've
never seen this before
take a look at this list you want to
start counting here's a 21 year old guy
in Greece February 3rd 2022 heart attack
dies here's a 29 year old pro athlete
heart a sudden expected death here you
go here's people who have heart issues
didn't die this person said it says they
died but they didn't write death on it
every time you see a red bar that's
death so let's just scroll down let's
just scroll down look at all this those
are deaths these are athletes who are
having direct issues with related to
their heart respiratory system or
they're just dying it is not an
assertion about vaccines I want to make
sure that's clear because I tweeted
about Demar 24 years old cardiac arrest
and then immediately some dudes like you
would love for this to be the vaccine
and I'm like what like I didn't even
bring that up why are you bringing that
up why are you associate I'm just saying
24 will have a heart attack that's crazy
yeah all I said was Cardiac Arrest 24
years old you have this air airtable.com
all of it has sources WPXI here you go
23 year old hockey player sudden
Unexpected death hockey player for
California University of Pennsylvania
died unexpectedly over the weekend
there's no it's not clear what led to
his death a whole bunch of these deaths
you want to see how long this list is
let me let me let me scroll down
start counting I I can't even I can't
look it's it's so massive here we go
we're two-thirds of the way through yeah
the dates are all 20 21 and 2022. now
look I'll say this I went through this
list randomly clicking links and the
stories exist I can't speak for every
single Post in here I don't know what I
know is I pulled up like 10 or 15 and
the stories are real these people all
died somehow for some reason I don't
know why so when Sanjay Gupta says this
of Demar I've never seen anything like
it bro are you reading the news because
this list is nuts look how it's still
going still going this got this there's
got to be thousands
thousands of affected people there was
another post by Dr Peter McCullough is
Peter McCall's number I'm getting ready
yes he said that they did the study and
found 50
1580 or some odd heart related issues
among athletes of that 1 101 deaths in
the past it was a year I think it was
prior to this 1 100 people had died in
the past 38 years here's my question
I have two questions what's causing it I
know a lot of people want to jump to
conclusions whatever those conclusions
may be and the other question is why is
it that so many people on social media
are assuming immediately it's the
vaccine
I know it's causing it it's climate
change
clearly no obviously that's what the
corporate media has been telling us
listen listen here it could also be
racism could also be video games but I
think
racism yeah that's a good point yes
absolutely I think that's racist just
saying
you're talking to a person of color
watch out here no no hey sorry Ian are
you trying to give Luke a heart attack
yeah well come on seriously all right
we need to be funny but people we were
talking about people Sunday group that
has his head in the sand literally and
to to blame what happened here on on
speculation is something that the
corporate media has been doing there
there was a post by a Chris haddock who
is claiming to be a physician and he's
blaming this this hit on the heart of a
tackle this one in a 200 million chance
of of him getting hit at the right time
at the right right where the heart was
was beating at this perfect time that
that stopped his heart for money that's
real it does happen it is real but it's
one in 200 million and the people spec
regulating this Chris haddock guy wrote
hey this is what's Happening Here
totally speculating here because he
doesn't know we still don't know what's
going on here we still don't know the
medical history we don't know if this
person did take the vaccine or didn't
take the vaccine okay it's not fair to
speculate but he's speculating and then
he's calling people who are also
speculating terrible and horrible people
you're doing what well you're accusing
people of doing what you're doing so so
made a good point they said these are
just a famous ones exactly these are
these are people who are on teams where
their deaths are noticeable and so it's
even high school college and
professional sports now look look D2 D3
uh especially high school what about the
ones that we don't hear about that that
we we of course know is happening as
well we don't know what's causing this
and what I mean by that is a lot of
people have assumptions a lot of people
are making predictions a lot of people
are looking for patterns but I'm saying
definitively we need an investigation
into this right now Sanjay Gupta may
have been saying I've never seen it
happen like he knows it happens but he's
never seen it and he mentions being
filmed that way but that's not how like
I'm not going to give him the benefit of
the doubt I'm not going to sit here and
try and justify what he's saying he's
like I've never seen it before typically
when someone says that they don't mean
physically see it they mean like like
hear of it happening or or witnessing
like an event or reading a chart or
something like this two things to break
down here uh another thing that I also
brought up a couple months ago on the
show was specifically insurance
companies coming out and raising the
alarms about excess debts especially
when it comes to males between the ages
of 18 and 35 talking about how there was
an alarming rate of young people dying
more than they ever have before two
What's Happening Here we don't know
because the government is standing in
the way from any kind of transparency
any kind of accountability any kind of
of data collection when it comes to
seeing what's actually going on here the
government is denying all of this as
they're still selling a product so if
there was some transparency if there was
some accountability like the government
of Florida is actually doing right now
which their Surgeon General came out and
said that there actually is a a
correlation between the two if we had
any of that we would have some trust we
wouldn't be speculating what's going on
here but because Bill Gates intervened
and told Donald Trump not to investigate
not to collect the data about what was
happening with the Trump scene Donald
Trump didn't have this investigation we
don't know what's going on here and
they're hiding the numbers they're
fudging the data and the data that's
coming out in other countries like the
United Kingdom is absolutely worrying
and is showing a picture that is worth
questioning and debating and and is
Connecting the Dots here let me let me
tell you what gives me pause
I I post this this story Cardiac Arrest
24 years old
and haters come out and say immediately
it's not the vaccine and I'm kind of
like why why are you bringing it up
here's what I think I think there are
people
who got vaccinated and got boosted
who personally inside themselves believe
something is wrong
and they assume the vaccine's causing it
but they don't want it to be true
because they fear for their own health
that's why they're coming out
immediately like no no but the reason I
bring that up is because I didn't even
say it this could be caused by coven
this could be caused by cardiovascular
damage caused by covet from people who
went untreated one of one of the
symptoms of covid one of the one of the
problems was lung scarring and what I
can't remember who we had on it might
have been Joe letipo from Florida
we were told that the spike protein of
covid Damages the microvascular system
in the body causing problems with
oxygenation of the blood it it also does
cause blood clotting I'm not saying
definitively that's what caused it I'm
not a doctor my point is how come these
people this guy didn't immediately
respond with I think covid is is causing
these deaths it makes the most sense no
the immediate thing he says is no no not
the vaccine and it's like
I don't think just one really quick
point you also get the spike protein not
just from covet but you also get it from
the vaccine for covet as well which is
an important note to mention sorry go
ahead and I think you don't have to jump
to conclusions to come to the conclusion
that this is not normal like a bunch of
20 year old kids who are healthy
otherwise healthy randomly dying is not
normal and that is something that
warrants questions it's something that
warrants an investigation like you said
and if you don't agree with that then
you are living again in this Blissful
ignorance or maybe dare I say it's a lot
more nefarious than just Blissful
ignorance right
um you're right it's not normal man and
last night on Monday Night Football in
front of the world like I think a lot of
people around the world are have heard
about the myocarditis from the Vex the
conversation about vaccines myocarditis
and they're thinking okay whatever
conspiracy will wait on that they just
saw a guy fall down on Monday night TV
and a lot of I think awoke a lot of
people or shook a lot of people into
into thinking more about yeah well it's
happening right right right the answer
to the question of why why are people
assuming it's the vaccine the answer
that question may be because there's a
lot of people on social media who are
saying this there's documentaries like
died suddenly and then you mentioned
regular people don't think anything of
it until they see a dude suffer from you
know cardiac arrest on the field and
then you know it's it's the opposite of
out of mind they see it so they
associate it but here's the point I want
to make I don't care for for making an
assertion as to what causes this I don't
care for that whatever you want to
believe you're entitled to believe I'm
just going to say this as always find a
doctor you know and trust as it pertains
to this airtable.com link with all of
these people who are injuring injured or
dying from heart issues
what we start we start with is we take
all of these stories We Begin
investigating these stories we've seen
data that suggests it is abnormal and
there is access mortality mortality
then we investigate these to find common
causes we do a legitimate investigation
and draw the conclusion after the fact
we don't say hey look a bunch of people
are dying I'm going to immediately
assume it's this no no hold on you're
allowed to do that but I think for the
sake of solving the problem waking up
normies and and making sure more people
don't die yeah we don't need to make
assertions we just actually do the
investigation yeah but the government at
the same time is saying no shut up no
investigations nothing is happening here
black is white don't don't pay attention
to what's really going on here don't pay
attention to the huge amount of excess
debts here you got nothing to worry
about just keep complying just keep
taking them which is absolutely crazy my
point which is spurring on the these
theories and I agree with you if we want
to wake up regular people who are being
lied to or or being gaslit the
government's saying nothing to see here
folks okay well there's something to see
here we just don't know what it is we
got to investigate in whatever way we
can if we had a good government and a
healthy Society the response to all of
this should have been hey this is really
tragic we should all learn how to do CPR
and let's wait to find out what's going
on here but we don't have a good
government we have a corrupted
government that has been bought off and
paid for by big Pharma that is doing
their bidding that is giving them no
liability liability and is going along
with their studies that they fudged that
they manipulated and pushing a product
that we still have no long-term studies
on that's that's that's that's a lot of
questions I think deserve to be answered
I'm not a medical professional I'm not
telling people here what to do but at
the same time hey my conclusion from all
of this is is you should be asking
questions uh it's not it's not terrible
to be asking questions the people who
are trying to Gaslight you are some of
the people that are speculating and
trying to literally conjure up climate
change in order to excuse a lot of this
nonsense which is absolutely crazy
delusional kind of thinking when clearly
there's a lot of evidence there's a lot
of coincidences provided to us it's fair
to make those conclusions and at the end
of the day if we're left to win anything
from here is like hey learn how to do
CPR a lot of places a lot of communities
do it for free it's worth doing I had to
give someone CPR I once saved someone's
life giving someone CPR
um and
um I can't recommend it enough if you
guys get the chance to to learn learn it
do it please immediately because there's
going to be more of these cases coming
uh very very soon and so all all of your
points though it's like it should be
just as alarming if not equally so as
the fact that all of these people are
dying suddenly that people don't want to
even let you do what you described right
look into patterns look into
consistencies and it literally goes just
to the shirt that you're wearing if it's
it's not science if you can't question
it it's propaganda and so genuinely like
why is there such a resistance for
people just to know the truth to know if
there is a pattern if there isn't that's
okay we're okay with being disproven
we're not actually even making the
assertion there's nothing to disprove we
just want facts we want truth but also
too there's just seems to be like so
much resistance to it which I think
should concern everyone like why would
you even ban a documentary like died
suddenly from the internet if there
wasn't something there I don't know well
the censorship you know it's the Game of
Thrones quote from Tyrion Lannister when
you cut on cut out a Man's Tongue you
don't prove him wrong you only prove you
fear what he has to say yeah and
according to the CEO of one America a
National Life Insurance Corporation he's
talking about how there's an excess
debts of 40 percent in the third quarter
of 2021 that are not related to covid
specifically among the ages between of
18 through 64. what's causing a 40
increase in excess debts that's a
question worth asking especially when
the data is clear that it's not related
to covid what's going on here it it's
something that should be worrying a lot
of people it should be something that we
should be having debates and
conversations on it should be something
that the corporate media should be
focusing on but of course they're
telling you just sweep it under the rug
don't worry about it and because of that
this is one reason why we have to hold
them responsible for this and why they
might be culpable in all of this
especially with all the big Pharma money
that they're taking from Pfizer and
other large multinational corporations
that previously bribed regulators and
doctors in the media in order to of
course gain profit and screw everyone
else over which they have a record in
history of doing someone saying it's uh
the list is 304 Adverse Events that are
that are listed in this but these are
all news cited stories yeah so this is
you know articles were written and
published that people could then
reference to so one of the weird things
about this story right now that we're
talking about with Demar getting hit or
hitting that guy and whatever you know
what happened is that the NFL canceled
the game in the middle of the game it's
the first time in history well since
1933 I'm reading about it that uh ever
for an injury as a game been canceled
that's what I thought was crazy that's
so weird and then the every team in the
NFL changed their Twitter profile their
profile to Demars Jersey like there's
like there's some sort of guilt
Collective guilt what do they do to this
I think getting canceled in the game
right I don't think that any player on
that team could have played that game
and in in any good faith or an ability
with what had happened
um you know but what happened it is
unprecedented you know but look we'll
know soon I've I've seen people taken
off the field in stretchers before I've
seen people get knocked out and like go
limp but the game wasn't canceled yeah
this is it like evosh tweeted something
he's a leftist he's like oh no a
football player got injured on the field
must be something fishy and I'm like
yeah bro we got Ninja on the field and
they shut the game down everyone started
crying I'm like yeah I don't know I'm
not a big football guy I've watched a
lot of games I've seen a lot of injuries
I've watched videos where like bass
there was one it wasn't like a
basketball player recently hit his head
and get knocked out and they it was like
a huge shock they kept playing
yeah people people get injured and
someone else comes in yeah I think I
think I've never seen an injury where
they actually have an ambulance come on
to the field and take someone out in
that way I think that was probably what
was drawing a lot of people similar to
the way you said people that weren't
thinking about this Cardiac Arrest stuff
or anything like that they this was like
something that made it front of mind for
them and I think it just speaks to how
catastrophic it really was to watch like
I've seen some crazy injuries like in
football games and things like this but
like this like I'm probably it's one of
those memories I feel like is going to
be according the guy is still in
critical condition right now as we're
speaking um and and we're also hearing
from the chat I don't know if this is
true or not but they're saying that the
game wasn't canceled but the team said
that they refused to play yeah so so
well yeah yeah that I think it's worth
mentioning from Yahoo two hours ago uh
article comes out the NFL canceled the
game for Demar Hanlon it reads it didn't
after Chuck Hughes died on the field in
1971. so we have I don't know times
change maybe yeah true like we are in
this was the number one turning topic
like literally five minutes after it
happened we're on the show people were
like dude just collapsed I saw it in the
chat it was just dominating and everyone
was talking about it well I guess uh
hopefully dude is okay we'll see how
this one goes hard segue time we got the
story from timcast.com Canadian College
threatens Jordan Peterson's medical
license demands social media
Communications training uh Christopher
Bertman wrote this story uh you know
this this these journalists I got to
tell you here's my headline suggestion
Jordan Peterson threatened with
revocation uh is that the right word of
medical license unless he submits to
re-education yeah I'm just kidding Chris
did a good job we don't we don't I don't
like the the framing but um in in fact
based news but me personally here's the
story that's it they're saying Jordan
Peterson has to submit to re-education
because he's offended people on social
media or they'll take his medical
license away I say Dr Jordan Peterson
I don't know if he really needs it at
this point I mean I understand he
probably enjoys practicing Clinical
Psychology I think he's probably doing
well for himself and this is an
opportunity to be something bigger than
just a one-on-one doctor again I know I
know it's it's his life it's his career
and everything but I think Jordan
Peterson is better off focused on
telling people to be responsible to be
individuals and things like that but
what again does it say about our society
today that they are literally trying to
take the medical license away from an
individual for nothing more than wrong
whoa whoa hold on hold on hold on hours
aside this is Canada okay
Canada we're well on our way
yep yeah so Jordan Peterson tweeted the
Ontario College of psychologists has
demanded that I submit myself to
mandatory social media Communications
retraining with their experts for among
other crimes retweeting Pierre uh poilev
how do you pronounce it
and criticizing Justin Trudeau and his
political allies amazing about a dozen
people fall over the world submitted
complaints about my public statements on
Twitter and Rogan Over a four-year
period out of 15 million who follow me
on social media claiming that I had
harmed people with My Views not them
he says I've been accused of harming
people uh what does it say uh
I have my kids apartment people although
none of the complaints involved clients
of mine or anything like that if I
comply with the terms of my re-education
and my pun my punishment will be
announced publicly I have already had
the second most serious category of
punishment levied against me and I have
been deemed at high risk to reoffend oh
my
I am willing if Ontario CP Ontario
occurs which they won't to make
absolutely every word of all of this
fully public so that everyone can decide
for themselves what is actually
happening here we go man it reminds me
that episode of Simpsons when Homer
makes the Time Machine toaster and he
goes back in time and then he like kills
a mosquito then he goes forward in time
and Ned Flanders controls everything and
then you have to get re-educated and
Flanders but but the reason I bring this
one up is that Flanders is this hokey
nice guy good neighbor but then in this
in this treehouse of Horrors episode
he's an authoritarian so what happens is
you have Canada putting on this air of
We're the nice oh sorry about that you
know we're gonna do a good man make sure
nobody's getting harmed eh better submit
to re-education before you lose your
medical license and have your life
destroyed they were always passive
aggressive I was the niceness was always
fake I was always calling it out with
the Canadians I was I was banned from
Canada aren't you I was banned for 10
years the son of a guns I have to get a
lawyer fight these better
fought to go to Canada why because he's
a real American
you must really like poutine no I didn't
and there was I was dating a chick and I
needed to see her family and the rest of
your family I demand to be led into
Canada I know I'm not proud of that okay
stop cry just escaped he like he he
jumped over the wall and was running so
it feels like I'm thinking like Einstein
before Nazi Germany fled Nazi Germany
before they started cracking down the
Jews and what is Peterson doing in
Canada right now when they're
threatening to strip him of his license
for and I agree with you Tim I don't
think that his that his psychology
license is his crowning achievement even
close to it when history looks at Jordan
Peterson they'll remember the things he
said and things he did he's helping
young people who are lost come back to
responsibility save my life in 2017. I
directly attributed to that man's voice
I I was I was checked out I mean I don't
want to get in I'm not wasting time here
he saved my [ __ ] life dude this guy I
who Jordan yeah
like he just woke up something in my
spirit that reminded me that I have
something to do here isn't that crazy
it's wild it's like this dude who just
comes around and just says find the
heaviest thing you can't you can carry
and carry it and then all of a sudden
he's basically
a father figure to so many people who
did not have a strong masculine presence
but Jordan Peterson is not the most
masculine dude I'm not going to be a
dick like he cries a lot you know what I
mean
he like breaks down and gets made fun of
for crying all the time and he suffers
himself but you have this guy who comes
out and he's just like do it clean your
room and then people are like yeah yeah
and then he writes 600 pages on it and
then does 80 other things and gives
talks and TV shows he's just a
magnificent polymath I like the guy but
maybe it's because of what he's doing
for young men like you like so many
people across the world that's why they
want to silence him you know it's the
same thing that people have said about
like Andrew Tate whether you like him or
not
why is him giving young men confidence
such a thing like to hate him for right
um and it I think it just goes to the
fact that in our society today there's
been such a war on masculinity a war on
strong male role models in so many ways
uh and it leads to things like this or
literally trying to take his medical
license away
um for telling you to clean your room
essentially and for daring to believe in
just common sense and reality but look
look if I'm gonna do it everybody under
the chicken analogy if I went out to
collect the eggs in the chicken coop Kim
does it but you know if I went out there
and there was a rooster that was telling
all the chickens not to let me take the
eggs I'd be upset with that I would I
would remove that riff like I walk in
one day and I'm like where are the eggs
the chickens are all like give me a look
and they're like you can't take the eggs
I'm like what's going on these chickens
standing up for themselves yeah can't
have that get that rooster out of there
that's exactly what it is the
establishment politicians the elites the
corporate Executives the Bill Gates
types don't like the idea that some dude
is rallying people to be individuals to
stand up for themselves no you will owe
nothing and you will be happy then
Jordan Peterson comes around and says
work hard have a family be responsible
for yourself and they're like stop stop
stop yeah shut them up how dare you tell
people to be self-sufficient human
beings and society today well exactly
it's bad for communism yeah if people
are independent you don't get communism
it's bad for the state they need you
weak they need you decide then you do
pathetic and the Canadian government has
been hijacked by the world economic
Forum admittedly even by Klaus Schwab
who said that the organization his young
leaders organization infiltrated more
than half of the parliament inside of uh
the Canadian government and what has the
Canadian government done ever since ever
since being influenced and taken over by
the world economic Forum well uh they
banned a protest they called in a
National Emergency arrested the protest
leaders deep back to them they there
they recently took away guns from from
law-abiding citizens and now there's
re-education camps here I'm seeing a
trend here of what's happening in Canada
and it's not a good one the worst thing
they did was they put a guy in Power who
talks like this and that's funny
everyone we don't need guns that's how
that's how Trudeau talks and that's the
that's the worst thing of it because
like at least Obama was charismatic he'd
step up there and be like hey I'm a
smooth talking celebrity and I'm gonna
blow up kids and you're like that's all
right we're going to hell yeah and he
really doesn't smile it's so weird like
how does he not know that that's weird
he grew up rich insulated with like prep
school and like he's an effeminate soy
boy actor just reading reading the lines
being told what to do implementing the
policies of the great reset that's all
he's doing he's an actor and he's a
great actor and Canadian Parliament is a
performance if you watch those guys
scream and yell and talk over each other
like how are you gonna get so you allow
each other to speak over each other
what's the point of that is
have you seen Paulie ever speak have you
seen the guy oh you should you should
watch him he's definitely gotta he's
definitely got something this is the guy
Peterson shout it out can you imagine
Trudeau when he's like 70. he's gonna be
like Herbert from Family Guy or or
exactly like Phil or exactly like Fidel
it's gonna be funny they're gonna look
his pictures and be like hey look at the
same guy no but he's gonna be like
Herbert he's gonna be like hey there why
don't you give me your guns give me your
guns little boy how long is this allowed
to be in power according to Canadian
government
the way things are going up there
probably forever he's probably gonna be
Emperor Trudeau and there's going to be
nothing that could stop him you try to
protest him he'll shut it down he'll
take away your bank account he's taken
away people's guns he's taken away
people's ability to have free speech
he's taken away parents ability to
decide what their children should be in
this world so it's it's a Total Takeover
of society total enslavement of humanity
that of course is following the
protocols of Klaus Schwab's great reset
uh they're they're building back better
but they're creating a situation A
dystopian one that really goes and and
and is really surrounding the UN 2030
Vision I spoke very highly of Jordan
Peterson about five minutes ago I'm
going to criticize Jordan I'm going to
criticize you now because I think what
brought this on is your victory real via
text in social media doesn't translate
the way that voice translates so when
you get angry and you write the angry
things out it's going to tweak people in
a way that your voice won't keep that in
mind moving forward
I like this Jordan Peterson guy pretty
cool you know I mean that's good family
too well you know I I think overall he's
a net positive there are some things to
criticize especially with his
relationship with big Pharma especially
with him kind of being a proponent of of
the the coveted vaccine as well there's
there's some things to to kind of be
critical of but at the end of the day
when you look at his kind of work that
he has done I I think it's a net
positive especially with how much he has
influenced young men that didn't have a
role model that didn't have anyone
telling them to clean up their room to
be responsible for themselves uh so I
think with any human being you can't
really judge him you just kind of gotta
uh you know see them for who they are
all right so question when Donald Trump
wins speaker of the house and then they
impeach Biden and Kamala and then the
Senate convicts that convicts them
somehow and that makes Donald Trump
president again do we invade Canada and
liberate it yeah liberate it now we will
be welcomed as liberators I think we
will that's right yeah we'll come in the
people of Canada scream and cheer as
American tanks roll down their borders
and if we do it right Alberta will just
become a United State and then we'll
continue to expand the United States of
Earth to create a decentralized
organization yeah
go back in time to the war 1812. we
almost took uh Quebec yeah true we like
invaded and like went to Montreal the
United States did and then the British
came and burned down the way I think
Canada and United States is a great kind
of uh experiment because we're right
next to each other geographically we
both speak English for the most part and
our governments are like different and
you see how the difference is affecting
the communities the way people are being
threatened to lose their license for
speaking on social media again I'm not
saying it's not happening at all in the
United States because Pierre Corey lots
of different scientists were shut down
but I haven't seen that Peter McCall
wasn't stripped of his license for
speaking out against coven but it is
crazy policies how the government
colluded with a big Tech we're seeing in
the Twitter files to uh let's let's
let's talk about the Twitter files man
we got this right here let me let me let
me pull this one up you're gonna love it
Hillary Clinton in spite of democrat
Witch Hunt against Twitter to look for
Russian accounts that simply didn't
exist and four social media giant into
the arms of the FBI then we got this one
Adam Schiff lobbied Twitter to ban
journalists over q a conspiracies and
then we got this one right from mataibi
quote reporters know this is a model
that works
that's a cycle threatened legislation
wedded to scare headlines pushed by
Congressional Intel sources followed by
Twitter caving the moderation asks
basically the journalists ran on it so
what we have is the government colluding
with big Tech to shut down anyone who
had a descending opinion
welcome to the nightmare dystopia we
make fun of Canada all day and night ah
Canada's so bad Trudeau so Trudeau so
bad look what we're living in yeah yeah
when the when the care the trucker
Convoy was going Biden flew up there to
tell Trudeau to do something and then
flew back and they cracked down on it
EMT correct you Peter McCullough is
losing his medical licenses and
credentials uh he just lost it by the
Texas Medical Board and he's being
threatened like many doctors and and and
other doctors have been stripped of
their licenses for not going along with
the larger agenda it's the thing that
happens in Canada it can happen here
very very quickly that's why we've got
to speak up and get get loud about this
happening in California they just passed
a law that uh that doctors can be held
accountable for so-called coveted
misinformation if
you have a medical opinion that goes
against the government
there you go yeah that's crazy
but yeah to your point though I think
that like what is happening in Canada
like we can joke about it we can laugh
about it but it should also be a blaring
warning to all of us about what America
could become if we are not Vigilant uh
because this stuff we're seeing it at a
micro level in very blue States in
California you're seeing the code
misinformation laws targeting doctors
you're seeing you know people being
canceled for different opinions through
big Tech collusion you have you know
organizations like prageru that couldn't
advertise on the internet because we
were apparently teaching young people
that they are not victims and all these
things it's it's absolute insanity and
it's like we literally will become
exactly what we fear in Canada if we
don't open our eyes and actually fight
to take back this country in a real way
what's the coveted misinformation law in
California you mentioned yeah so it's
literally if a doctor says something
that goes against the you know the the
current science of of the matter so
whatever you know fauci is recommending
or whatever they can be held accountable
and they can have their medical licenses
revoked and suspended um whose authority
under the medical board of California
that grants them the licensing and this
is it they just speak out against an
established if they provide it if they
provide medical advice as contrary to
that that they believe is not helpful or
I guess fruitful to whatever they're
trying to accomplish then yeah they can
be reported to the medical board of
California where they can then face
penalties and sanctions for the medical
device if they don't Implement
um you know the procedures that the
government wants them to implement on
everyone else they lose their license in
in Germany there was just a doctor that
was sentenced to two years in jail
because he was giving out mask
exemptions and allegedly to the state he
was giving it giving out Mass exemptions
to the wrong people because of that he's
literally ending up in jail for two
years this it reminds me of what the
pharmaceutical industry did I think it
was in the 90s when they started
treating pain it was all about treating
pain and if you don't give them enough
opiates to treat their pain then you're
going to lose your medical license so
these doctors were forced to start
essentially drugging poisoning and
addicting people to opioids and Dr Drew
was talking about this on the episode
when he was on IRL is fascinating and it
completely I mean he didn't annihilate
the medical industry but he said doctors
were in fear uh to practice because they
thought if they did what they thought
was the right thing they'd lose their
license this Pharma industry is just too
too tentacled in right now and I'm not
sure it's disgusting like truly and
truthfully if you can't trust your
physician to do what they believe is
right because they are fearful of what
the implications may be on their ability
to even practice medicine then where can
you truly get good advice about anything
anymore right can't get it on Twitter
you're getting banned from there if you
spread so-called well maybe not now if
Elon Musk at the helm but before that
was the case if you dare to suggest an
alternate theory about how you should
treat covid-19 or how you should address
it you were banned you were censored in
all these things it's absolutely or even
talking about early treatment which we
should have been talking about which
many Mainline professionals are saying
hey if there was early treatment we
could have saved and prevented a lot of
excess debts we could have prevented so
much misery but but the main consensus
was like shut up you're sick who cares
uh come to the hospital if you turn blue
yeah that's that's it
that's it proposal not not even that I
mean when when I got covered I called
the hospital and they said good luck
that's it yeah and then I was like okay
guys and then I got really really bad
and so I did this I did what any smart
intelligent person would do I called Joe
Rogan
and that's half true when the hospital
was basically like stay home do nothing
I was like okay and then I ignored it
and then I started getting sicker and
sicker and then I knew Joe had talked
about the treatment he did so I hit him
up and then you know he was like get a
private doctor and talk to them about
options don't just like you can't rely
on these these like this public these
public hospitals are like we're
overwhelmed we don't care stay home
you're young don't worry about it and uh
yeah it's funny how that was like the
gag like Joe Rogan became this health
expert yeah that was funny well he he
platformed a bunch of Health experts I
don't think he would ever call himself a
health expert no I mean I mean I mean
that somewhat facetiously the media was
arguing he wasn't he wasn't saying he
was he made that comment about young
people not eating vaccines or whatever
then the media went nuts against him and
then he was like look the podcast
comedian like go talk to a doctor yeah I
trust him on nutrition that's for sure
he's definitely I don't know I wouldn't
consider him a nutritionist but do you
guys know medically regarding like
someone like Peter Mccalla who has Texas
strip his Texas state license can he
like go to Florida and get a license in
Florida not a practice but then he would
have to move or something probably so
like you could offer doctors sanctuary
in a state yeah okay I think yeah well
different states I would assume have
different like medical licensing
standards and so if you're stripped in
one state maybe there could be a
protection offered out and I'm sure if
he goes to Florida they'd reinstate they
gave him a license especially
considering Florida's position on most
things I'm more and more bullish that
DeSantis has got to stay in Florida's
governor yeah it's so I don't know I
mean I kind of feel like if he can bring
that leadership to the rest of the
country we'd be in a better position do
you think he can through the White House
yeah
let me do it he's not the legislature
here's the thing in Florida you've got
Republican legislature right I'm pretty
sure Luke
it's republican-controlled legislature I
believe so those chambers yeah so it's
easy for this and just to get things
done when he's got support in in you
know Florida's uh House of reps or
whatever in Senate it wasn't always like
that though right and that won't be the
case in the right in the United States
if descendence becomes president with a
gridlocked congress then he's not going
to get things done just he's sitting
there saying no to stuff but you still
have a lot of power and and you know at
least we won't have Dr fauci at the helm
calling the shots what if the Santa says
the uh
is the guy who crosses the Rubicon you
think terrifying what would be the
Rubicon is it terrifying
the the yeah because that was a military
coup I understand but then you see 200
years was it like 200 years of
prosperity in the Roman Empire that's
debatable uh you got to find Prosperity
a lot of the standard of living
plummeted after it well no I don't know
we talked about it before and someone
mentioned that it actually improved a
little bit I know like Emperors were
getting assassinated back and forth yeah
for a long time and Leadership kept
changing hands CJ what do you think
there's a big debate Trump or DeSantis
where do you stand you know I think I
think at the end of the day desensis
record is incredibly strong right and I
think to your point when you talk about
his the way that he's maneuvered through
the legislature there's been times when
they didn't want to do a lot of the
things that he's been doing
um when you look at him redrawing those
uh Maps uh for congressional
representation there are a lot of people
in the legislature who are like no
DeSantis we don't want you to do that
and he was like no I'm gonna do it and
you guys are going to pass it and he did
it and I think that when you talk about
these really important culture wars are
in front of us about how do we actually
protect our children from grooming how
do we you know actually tackle things
like inflation and just get our country
back on the right moral course we need
someone who knows how to actually use
their power which I think
is one of the most prominent criticisms
of you know previous administrations is
that we have all chambers of government
but we don't know how to actually use
the power when we have it right why did
we not defund Planned Parenthood when we
controlled all chambers of government
that never happened and I think there's
no excuse for something like that
um it's it's because they don't actually
want to yeah I mean like you can't trust
them yeah we don't we didn't get term
limits we like if how long did it take
to repeal Obamacare if we ever really
ended up doing that in its entirety like
that's the thing it was it we had
someone on the show and they said that
um it was one of the freedom caucus guys
that he was the last vote to repeal
Obamacare and they came to him and said
no no don't do it we need it we needed
to campaign it's insane
that's what they uh McCarthy's team was
saying uh earlier today they were like
you know basically saying of Matt Gates
he he wins by losing yeah when the
Democrats win he can then campaign
against Democrats say they're the
problem he can blame the establishment
there's always a path and that's a
manipulation for sure like people like
Matt gates are elected because he is
fighting that's the game they play
exactly
uh I was plugging my computer in like I
was talking about controlled opposition
who was he before he talked about Gates
who was the controlled opposition all of
them all politicians are controlling
their own but you were going on a little
time describing what was kind of going
on in Florida which I think was
interesting uh another thing that I
would add is that uh also one thing that
really kind of safeguarded DeSantis is
that he denied any Zucker bucks for
um reinforcing the elections uh down in
Florida because uh Facebook invested
hundreds of millions of dollars on
helping people vote predominantly
helping the Democrats vote and Florida
and DeSantis said no we're not going to
take your money and and I think because
of that that was one reason out of many
reasons why we had we you know the the
Santas had such a major victory down
there in Florida as well so it's
interesting seeing this larger fight
again there's a lot of also Shady people
surrounding themselves near DeSantis
because they kind of seek him as this
kind of New Hope uh for me be critical
of everyone but I think the record
stands for itself I mean he's he's very
much against the woke he's very much
again the lockdowns the the mandates the
vaccines and he's actually investigating
it which is going to be very fascinating
to see the results of these
investigations when it comes to
myocarditis when it comes to people
getting ill getting sick and being
injured by this we're finally soon going
to find out what the correlation
actually is because his state is one of
the few states in the union that's going
to be tracking the data which I think is
extremely Brave extremely important and
something that we need desperately more
than ever yeah and you know let me make
myself clear too you know I love
president Trump and I love Governor Ron
DeSantis and whatever happens will
happen but I think what we truly do need
are people who number one are willing to
fight unlike what we have seen from
these establishment shells who have just
shown a reluctance to actually speak
truth to power at times and people who
are not afraid to take on the system and
use the Mandate that they have to
actually govern in a real way
um that's we like we can't go back to
the days of this passive conservatism
because that's not the battle we're in
today we have people literally trying to
change the genders of toddlers we have
you know this rampant indoctrination
happening in our campuses all across the
country we are in a battle for the heart
and soul of America we don't we're not
going to win that battle by being nice
anymore and I think that this this nice
guy era of politics it's unfortunate
it's come to an end but you cannot look
at the news each and every day and say
that it hasn't I think the key uh
economic is how to win politics is Win
economically because if you control the
market you control everything uh they're
all they all need money all these
politicians but let me I'll tell you a
story I I when I was uh 18 and I was
broke as broken B I had one pair of
pants and they were they the crotch
explodes right you skate in his pair of
stretch jeans eventually the crotch
explodes so what did I do I I got some
duct tape and then I just duct taped
both the outside and the inside and then
I pressed it with an iron and then uh
you know hey it's a patch start skating
in them ripped the lag I fell and I put
duct tape on both sides every time that
was a hole and then one one day I'm with
like some family and there's some buyer
for a big like you know department store
chain and then she's like those pants
are amazing did you make that and I was
like yeah and she's like wow that
Design's brilliant I was like it's not a
design I just have holes in my pants so
I duct tape them shut there is this
there is something about that
I don't know my my point is just
there it's not all about having the
money it's about the culture and the
culture can be developed by people who
don't have money and if you can
influence people you eventually will
make the money like if those pants did
end up selling you'd make a bunch of
money off garbage pants they sell those
hats where the brims are already Frayed
on it like it's yeah they sell they sell
pants that have fake underwear sewed in
it's it's it's it's a lot of it's fake
it's not about so much but but I don't I
don't disagree I'm in my statement it's
about the goods and the services and
some of those are Necessities I don't
think those should be for profit I think
but a lot of the the you know the
Cosmetic stuff people want that's
cultural like you you can create people
to want certain things and then so in
that sense it is the culture dictating
what Commodities people want in the
market and what then they're willing to
say it's the ESG essentially it's it's a
lot of the bigger Financial backers the
black rocks of the financial institution
saying No this is where the money is
going to be invested in this is where
the money's going to be put in this is
the ideas that we're going to promote
you promote any other ideas we're going
to take away our funding we're going to
put money where we want it to be funded
and that of course is destroying the
family unit degeneracy nonsense bullcrap
and the larger divide and conquer agenda
that are screwing over society and
destroying Humanity from the inside yeah
Vivek Rama Swami I'll bring it up again
uh on the show a few weeks ago I don't
know if you saw the episode or not but
he's uh he's an economist essentially
this I don't know if he considers
himself an economist if he's technically
one but he's uh talking about the
indexes and how BlackRock controls the
indexes they take your 401k if you just
give it to your company and then they
invest it in whatever they want and if
it's impact investment for climate
change whatever they're doing that so
he's created a new index type of index
where people can send their 401ks local
or or send your investment in retirement
plans local to some company it's not
BlackRock yeah I believe Florida and
West Virginia also made very similar
moves uh themselves as well West
Virginia I think did it first with with
Banning that stuff it was West Virginia
first yeah let's uh let's talk about uh
the collapse in the United States
because we have this story here from the
near post Mia M.I.A says is it Mia
M.I.A says she faced career backlash for
saying Jesus is real well that of course
explains why this country is falling
apart I'm only half kidding actually Mia
says the fact the biggest backlash in my
career and life I'm facing after saying
Jesus is real is such a revelation to me
people who control these apps rather me
be a bad girl than a good one
that right there says it all
this is she's well she's a rapper is
that what she does
um say r b r b and the Machine goes
after her because she says Jesus is real
I I I'm not a staunch Christian you know
religious person I do believe in God but
that says a lot to me when she says
they'd rather her be a bad girl they
want kids to have bad influences they
want degeneracy the algorithms of tick
tock versus in the United States versus
China and China's engineering and
Science in the United States it's
pronouns and gender I was talking about
I was learning about Kinsey last night
you guys know this doctor oh yeah
Sheamus sex doctor and he is one of his
students was Hugh Hefner who later
became the Playboy guys started Playboy
and they were all about sexualizing
Society they'd go to colleges and
they're like we are going to sexualize
everybody yeah man let's do it and
that's we're still looking at it now
we're down to generacy without any shame
at all and it's a shame that today it's
more controversial for a celebrity to
say that Jesus is real uh then for them
to suggest that oh maybe they're there
are two genders or maybe that toddlers
shouldn't have sex changes or maybe the
world isn't systemically racist they are
targeted for having their own personal
beliefs and faith and for in her example
wanting to be a good girl not wanting to
be some only fans model who is teaching
young girls they have to shop their
bodies around for validation when all
actuality like like what truly are they
trying to criminalize here what kind of
thought are they really trying to
demotivate and and and it's sickening
because as you said it it it's the first
step towards this grooming um not just
in the sense of sexualizing young
children but also trying to over
sexualize just even adults like why
can't women young women women who aren't
children have good role models and why
can't they believe that Jesus is real
it's absolutely insane is there a
context for her statement did you guys
ever she's she's recently uh become
religious and uh she's she says I
believe in it I'm not gonna lie to you
she said it on stage age I don't know I
think she tweeted it yeah just just
those three words basically all my fans
might turn against me because they are
all progressives who hate people that
believe in Jesus Christ in this country
in an apple music interview even if it
cost me my career I won't lie I will
tell the truth and I will tell you
what's on my mind in my heart if I'm
coming back now saying Jesus Israel
there's a point Bravo man I think
there's a lot of atheists that are or or
just people maybe there's some sort of
realists that are like yo if a guy dies
then he's no longer real like he was
real but now he's gone I don't know man
I I feel like you you've got so many
people who believe in simulation Theory
as well as DMT the veil and machine
elves where I'm just like at a certain
point you've got to not like you could
be agnostic but I don't know how you be
atheists and just think that we're wet
robots that cease to exist when we die
yeah because we also have video of John
Lennon and like so is John Lennon real I
mean it's a weird argument and they're
gonna have like deep fakes of us after
we're gone
they're gonna take they can take your
your social media profiles and create a
fake version of your you that's creepy
dude yeah that's the singularity right
there you'll you will not exist but
there will be a weird facsimile of you
existing but my point is just like when
we have people come on the show or when
people go on Joe Rogan over and talk
about DMT and they talk about breaking
through the veil and seeing machine
elves and stuff it's like hey there's
something else beyond all this it's just
I don't know why people think that what
they can touch smell see in here is just
it and there's nothing else that's weird
to me yeah that's one dimension out of
many dimensions that we're all in that
we're all kind of and people people got
to understand man if you are just a wet
robot that is the electrical impulses in
your brain create the perception of you
that is a tiny fraction of the universe
the universe is massive electrical
impulses on a larger scale do you think
the the the the chemical Pathways and
the neurons in your brain is the most
intricate possible pattern that exists
there's something bigger than that like
let's
the the system that creates you in your
mind with the electrical impulses there
is a much larger version than that
version of that in the universe I
guarantee you you are not the end-all
be-all that's the crazy thing to me you
know what I mean how deep do you want to
go
down and it's such a symptom of the
narcissism I think that we see today
everyone just thinks things start with
them and end with them and so it's so
easy to just not want to believe in a
higher power in Jesus Christ and all
these things but for me as a Christian
it's personal because I feel like it
would be very hard to go day after day
without having faith in something bigger
than me
um and thinking that you know maybe like
there is a broader plan at play here and
so but yeah I think it really does to
your point just goes back to narcissism
that so many people have today whereas
we don't want to believe that there is
someone guiding us or something guiding
us you know I'll play this way if you
think you are just a wet robot and your
brain is a wet computer do you think the
human computer is the epitome the the
most powerful
wet computer that exists in the universe
that to me is an insane proposition that
someone could be like I think we're just
wet robots there's nothing else and it's
like okay well there's something 100
times more powerful than you as a wet
robot with better computational Powers
more perception and then to assume that
what we can touch smell see in here is
reality is insane to me yeah it's like
it's like Huber's almost yeah I was
asking chat GPT about Pride because I
get hung up on this Catholic Pride as a
sin but American Pride is a wonderful
thing and I'm like chat GPT you know
this AI program on the internet which
you should all check out chat GPT it's
fascinating
um what's what's the deal why do they
say it's a sin but we should do it and
it's like you know it is a sin but a
little is okay I'm like why is a
deadliest a little bit of a deadly sin
okay and it's like well uh some pride is
can be healthy but it is generally I'm
like uh well why some you know so I went
on with this computer and I think
there's a difference between self-love
and narcissism but we need to find that
within ourselves in the age of social
media it's very easy to fall into
narcissism like I would make an internet
video I put it up I'd watch it just to
you know watch it and then I find that
I'm enjoying it I like myself so I'd
watch it a second time I'm laughing I'm
like I want to watch it again and then
I'm like yo that's too far I'm becoming
nice you're tracking the likes you're
tracking the followers and then your own
self-worth is devalued if it doesn't hit
the the metrics that you wanted to right
so it's just like it's such a trap like
if you truly do fall in love with
yourself to the extent that you know you
also I feel like get a little bit of
validation from other people especially
in the world that we're in as content
creators it's just like you've got to
want you have to believe in something
more like I think for your own mental
health for your own well-being it's just
like I don't know it keeps me sane
personally but what got you to believing
that I think for me it was it's it's a
little bit of a selfishness of Peace of
Mind in a sense you know I think that
again believing in a higher power and
having the ability to have faith and and
a God and Jesus Christ uh is something
that has always been pivotal to just me
being able to say that I am not always
going to be in control and I'm okay with
that the things that are for me are for
me and the things that are not are not
uh and it's about just allowing yourself
to just kind of be at the whim of
something else for a little bit and not
just pretending as if you know
everything ends and starts with you
because I think that again it's a
narcissism that pervades our society
today but it's also something that's
incredibly prevalent within my
generation Generation Z it's like we are
the center of our universe when we're
not the center of everyone else is and I
think the sooner that you displace
yourself from that myth
um the happier you'll be because you'll
have so much less pressure on your own
shoulders when you actually just don't
believe that you are the end-all be all
to everything else
um when you have that that belief and
motivation of the power of something
outside of you how do you get motivated
personally I think for me it's that well
the belief I think is rooted in the fact
that you have to come from a place of
like where you we're at a Crossroads and
you didn't really know where you wanted
to go right like you you've tried
everything you've taken every turn
you've thought about all the options but
you just generally don't know and I
think you have to be to a place where
and the Bible talks about you have to be
humbled and you have to be brought to
your knees and you have to just seek
guidance from somewhere and I choose to
seek it from him and I think that like
that's just where I get the motivation
is that that God has a predestined
purpose for all of us and I think that
it would be
it would be a neglect of of my gifts and
my talents that he gave me to not
fulfill that by being motivated by being
you know someone who has a work ethic
right because it's just like my grandma
would say something to me oftentimes
when I was growing up is that God's your
talents are God's gift to you but what
you do with those talents is your gift
to God and I think like that's something
that like always resonated with me I
went through a phase where I was like yo
being famous being on stage being
wealthy everyone's screaming my name
while I'm playing for a crowd that's
narcissism man that's that's selfishness
I don't but what I realized was not
doing that is selfish I need to fulfill
my destiny or whatever this is goal yeah
that's it's it's ego to keep me from
doing it yeah the ego that's right you
know Ian hiding your talents and your
beautiful face from the world that's
pure narcissism everybody needs to see
more of you your ego can stop you from
becoming great and you need to keep your
ego in check that's interesting uh idea
though to be completely honest
they say that uh people who are so who
are famous tend to be narcissists
because these are the people who feel
like they need to be out there and
everyone needs to see them it's
interesting I thought you know like it
is part of their
the part of their Destiny part of their
your people who who are arrogant are
more likely to be famous because they
put themselves in these positions to
become famous and they believe they
deserve it too right they believe they
deserve the fame so they chase it more
actively exactly but I think it's
interesting is like you know we talk
about such big ideas even around this
table it takes a little bit of
narcissism to think that you have
solutions to these problems right which
is like it's it's the conundrum is that
like it you really do have to believe in
yourself to even be able to vocalize
like this is the direction we need to go
as a country this direction but again
it's it's unchecked narcissism and ego
but I don't I don't I wouldn't say
narcissism I think for some people it is
like you know if I come out and I say I
think Kevin McCarthy can't do the job I
think Ron Paul would do it better I
wouldn't call that narcissism I'm not
talking about myself I wouldn't want to
be in Congress I don't think I have the
solutions I just like to see somebody
else do it but sometimes you could do it
better and saying that is actually not
narcissistic you're just being self in a
way selfless like I don't want the role
but I could do it better so I'm going
gonna do it kind of there are some
there's a lot of things that I think
that of myself I'm really good at
complaining on the internet you know a
lot of people yeah prove it everyone
here at this table really good at it but
uh I'm I wouldn't pretend to be anywhere
near as good as like statesmanship than
someone like Ron Paul yeah like that
dude got elected several times he knows
how to speak to his constituents he knew
how to represent them effectively and
that's why he was in for as long as he
was he didn't become president though
that's a different ball game yeah you
know that's not statesmanship that's I
don't know what you'd call that it's got
to meet the moment I think at the end of
the day like yeah did you vote for Ron
Paul in 08 Luke you couldn't he wasn't
on the oh he didn't make that ballot no
were you well you could write him in
I think I I wrote in man bear pig that
year McCain hell are you crazy Mr Bama
Iran no no Moran yeah no way yeah him
and um
I mean it was like two uh narcissistic
sociopaths like McCain and Obama I I
literally put down man bear pig I had a
feeling that uh Ron Paul and 08 was
gonna be the bring balance to the force
I might have told you guys this before
it felt very much I was like oh it's
like what he's Darth Vader coming to
bring balance to the force and what that
means was he eradicated all the Jedi so
now there was none and there was a big
two so there was right but it was after
a total annihilation of the system and
maybe Ron would have oversaw an
annihilation of this system that's
imploding right now much quicker and
more controlled and that was the balance
that I was feeling he was going to bring
and but I wish I'd supported him looking
back I supported Obama because I liked
him but I think Ron Paul was the and
then there was uh Obama and Mitt Romney
again two sociopath crazy politicians
that again I think I also wrote in man
Bears basically like Obama's like if you
vote for me I'm gonna blow up kids and
Mitt Romney was like whoa whoa whoa hold
on hold on I completely agree and it's
like okay
not much of a choice there
yeah
all right everybody we're going to Super
chats if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share this show with
your friends become a member at
timcast.com
here's plan ladies and gentlemen we're
gonna have a members only uncensored
show coming up for you around we post
those around uh 10 50 11 p.m but uh as a
member not only are you getting access
to the uncensored content The Green Room
show cast Castle Tales from the inverted
World Etc
your membership allows us to build crazy
things and one of the ideas we have is
with the coffee shop that we're building
we want to do special Friday night shows
members only can hang out first floor we
do the show on the third floor but you
get to hang out and there'll be some
kind of meet and greet maybe hard
because of security
but we want to create members only
hangout portions and things like that
our members only events and uh we want
to set up these physical locations we
have the the coffee product is in the
works I think we're starting with four
four options two standard
um roasts and then two special Blends
and then we've also purchased the
building for the first coffee shop we
own it it is happening like no joke we
got to do the construction we got to
build the bar we got to install Plumbing
things like that but this will be in
West Virginia and I'm really excited for
it and then we're gonna hopefully start
setting up more and more of these
physical locations where you can hang
out how cool would that be someone walks
in for a cup of coffee and the TVs on
the walls are playing Tim cast IRL
they're playing viva viva and Barnes
they're playing with K to law they're
playing Stephen Crowder they're playing
these kinds of YouTube shows because
there's a whole bunch of live streams
that happen from morning until night and
it's not just pop culture crisis or you
know the shows that we have there's a
lot we've got a gamer show coming up
soon as well but a bunch of other
YouTubers as well I want to make a space
where people come in and they get
exposed to this kind of content that's
how we're going to do it one way we're
going to do it so smash that like button
let's read some super chats all right
dank says happy birthday to both the
Kenosha kid and the rothschild-backed
climate Gremlin they symbolize the
cultural divide Greta is a globalist
adored climate activist and Kyle's a
good kid with a gun I like that the
rothschild-backed climate Gremlin I I
told Kyle he needs to heal the world and
him and Greta need to come together and
become an official couple and and make a
child I don't know if his girlfriend
would like it he came out he's like I
got a girlfriend no it was a funny
conversation that we actually had
between each other but it you know they
share the same birthday
um and I think let's let's be real you
want to heal the world it's one way to
do it all right here we go rusta zero
says you won because you were playing
low skill character diva
so so what what what what but why do I
care about your favorite character and
OverWatch no I like playing Diva
sometimes I like Moira I like I like
playing the low skill characters because
I don't play that often uh I like Sombra
so you guys ever play OverWatch play the
first one OverWatch two sombra's great
uh she can uh trans she can teleport
basically and she can go invisible and
so I love just sneaking up on people and
then you know big fan of Genji uh yeah
Genji's all right I play a lot of Heroes
of the Storm and some of those OverWatch
characters make their way into the game
I don't care for any of the competitive
stuff I just play No Limits 5v5 where
like I was playing today and it was just
five winstons jumping around he's the
gorilla character so I just I'm just I'm
I'm playing I'm having fun dude like you
you know it's like you you won because
you played a low skill character I
probably I don't know I had a good time
though there's something that flow State
last night I was shaking I played a game
of Heroes of the Storm and my body was
shaking because I was in such The Zone
like I was dodging side stepping that's
called vitamin D deficiency and you need
to fix it you're working out and my New
Year's resolution you're gonna get it
from my personal trainer we're gonna set
you up with my personal trainer and
we're gonna do this 100 that's account
so what I do is I go to Twitter on the
early of the year I post my New Year's
resolution I pin it so every time I log
into Twitter go to my channel I have to
remind my I reminded what my resolution
I responded to it oh you did I was
nervous yeah yours is here is the gem
I'm building muscle this year last year
was fixing my posture and it was
extremely useful to see that when I
would go to Twitter every day or
whenever I would see it all right let's
see what we got here red Miss says buy
Ian's Grandpa's Crystal powered Envy
binos
you know we should make a coffee that's
like Ian's crazy Ian's gems blend and
then like when you open it for some
reason the coffee beans are multicolored
oh dude have you guys ever heard just a
bunch of crystal meth in there have you
ever heard of anaerobic coffee brewing
you can Brew it in no oxygen environment
or roasted in a low oxygen or I like
cold brew cold brew is amazing someone
sent me a list of a bunch of cool things
you can do with coffee Adrian Rodriguez
says I want to buy the first franchise
of your coffee shops in Florida let's do
it well some people are saying we should
franchise but I don't I mean maybe I
kind of just don't know if we would even
do that I just don't I I'm not that I
don't know man is it profitable yeah
it's very franchising is extremely
profitable like like subway is mostly
franchises I'm pretty sure Chick-fil-A
does a lot of franchising but I miss I
don't I don't know
I'd rather just own it you know content
quality you got to make sure that you're
overseeing quality control yeah exactly
I think Chick-fil-A only allows
franchisees to have one location yeah
for Quality reasons
all right Emissary of dickishness says
leveled
LMFAO tell me you didn't watch the game
without telling me you didn't watch he
didn't throw a flying cross arm bar at
the guy and knock him three feet I know
but he grabbed them swung them and took
him down pretty hard I mean well not
that hard Christopher Harris says next
to a government shutdown the U.S house
being unable to function for an
indefinite period doesn't sound so bad
thank you the approval rating for
Congress is like 27 or something yeah so
I'm just like I don't care like whatever
dude
I think it's funny
and I don't I don't I don't what it what
did McCarthy say he's not going to
impeach Biden
they say that no he said something about
investigating though and I'm just like I
don't trust him dude he said he knows he
knows there's a lot of Maga candidates
America First candidates and he's got to
win them over and he can't that's what
he so he's trying I know he released
some plans for some committee
assignments he had like the committee to
investigate China a subcommittee to
investigate the weaponization the
federal government again these were some
of his concessions he made the freedom
caucus but I don't know if he's made any
like Biden specific
investigation Quantum strange Quark says
didn't Jim Jordan say he didn't want to
be speaker of the house and wanted to be
involved with the actual investigations
instead yeah happy New Year missed you
all last week it was a fun vacation I
went to uh Savannah Georgia it was cool
how was it uh it's cool Savannah's cool
place January I think is the best
December best time to be there it was
like 50 60 degrees so it's fun and all
the trees have the Spanish moss hanging
from them looks super creepy yeah very
everything's haunted apparently
there's ghosts everywhere there's a
serial killer Museum which is crazy one
thing I learned is that a lot of serial
killers were forced to dress up like
little girls when they were when they
were children oh wow that's weird
I don't know it's what's a lot but we
saw a bunch of them where it's like this
serial Killer's mother forced him to
wear girl's clothing when he was a child
and I'm like wow so does this mean we're
gonna have like a lot of serial killers
oh I'm not saying that I think we are
absolutely
unfortunately learn self-defense stay
strapped I recommend it dude it's cool
in in Savannah you can drink you can
drink on the street
yeah you got to put in a plastic cup but
you're allowed to drink booze as you
walk around because it's a tourist City
so the river walks really awesome
there's a guy playing trumpet you know
hanging out in the balcony watching some
guy play you know a bunch of different
trumpet songs any hot spots people
should visit while they're there oh I
don't know man you said where do we go
the The River the River Street walk or
whatever just walking up and down yeah
yeah I'm from Augustus I'm like three
hours away from all right on Sheamus uh
Sheamus lives there yeah so he got
really excited yeah there's the Rooftop
Bar on uh I can't remember the name of
the hotel whatever I forgot sorry guys
it'll come to you can't tell you but we
ate dinner at the Fitzroy that was
really really great one of the best
chicken schnitzels I've ever had
seriously no no joke it was really good
are you related to Sheamus no okay well
they were distant cousins I don't know
we went to this breakfast place called
Collins Court or whatever and then the
server was like where you going for
dinner and we were like I don't go to
Fitzroy and I was like okay he's like I
worked there and I was like oh cool it's
like ask for Zach and I was like all
right so we did we showed up and we were
like we were told to come and they're
like we'll squeeze you in and like and
we have to be served by your server's
act and then they were like okay he's
upstairs and then we did and it was
awesome they had like triple they had
french fries with three aiolis so dude
shout out to Zach man nice job yeah we
it was good food man they had they had
filet mignon good stuff it was fun it
was fun to go down there and uh we
waited for half an hour in line at
Leopold's Ice Cream because apparently
that's what you're supposed to do and I
had uh cookies squared was the ice cream
I got good holiday good good holiday
totally worth it
and then apparently Leopold's Ice Cream
it's like some Hollywood movie Producers
so he's got like a bunch of movies
posters on the walls for the things he's
worked on yeah Stratton Leopold I think
his name is
Andre says Michael malice for speaker
seconded yeah seconded
all right let's see what they got
I am pandasis pandysis says Tim please
tell everyone who wants Jim Jordan to go
on their social media and message their
reps and tell them that's what they want
it's very easy to tell our reps what we
want in that Way in real time
absolutely let's do it so what do you do
you tweet at Jim Jordan and then just
get like 500 5000 people to retweet it
or something call your reps now I think
tweeting at them works because uh you
can do it right now emailing but they'll
get it you got it you gotta you gotta
put the pressure on and be like hey man
look I voted for you don't vote for
McCarthy so you call your rep at like
one o'clock P.M your time tomorrow and
leave a message with their office
letting them know you want tweet Adam
I think phone call a lot of phone calls
can really push the
push the uh the needle what the
activists do and what we used to do when
we did canvassing is they would give you
10 postcards and you'd stop someone and
ask them if they didn't want to give
money you could be like okay well here
would you want to fill out this postcard
then what they do is they take if if
they get you know 100 postcards per
employee and they get they get up with 4
000 postcards per week then what they do
is the end of the month they take
something like what I got 16 000
postcards and they mail them all at once
then the rep walks into their office
with a stack of 16 000 postcards and
they go what is this and it's it's your
constituents telling you what they
expect from you otherwise you won't win
and they go okay okay I get it it's
effective man very effective
KF says Tim curious to know how Mr bocus
is doing hope all is well Mr bocus is
extremely gaunt
and I don't know how much time he has
left the subcutaneous IV fluids seem to
have very much helped
uh so every other day we give him an IV
you pinch the skin you stick a needle in
and then electrolyte solution goes under
his skin his body absorbs it he's also
getting a hormone treatment to stimulate
red blood red blood cells but he doesn't
want to eat
um he is eating but he's very like he
complains and then eventually eats which
is good but the other day we couldn't
find him and we found we eventually
found him hiding buried in the closet
it's a really bad sign yeah cats go into
hiding when they're when they're sick
and bad things are happening so he's uh
when I made that video he was like
stumbling and couldn't stand up we
started giving him the solution and now
the hemoglobin treatment and he's acting
normal which is good but he's still
losing weight so we don't know how much
time he's got left gotta get him
inspired to eat I think we'll mix a
little wet food maybe a five to one dry
to wet ratio we give him exactly like we
have to give him kidney special food for
because of his kidneys are basically are
dead so he can't have certain foods that
are high in certain uh chemicals uh I'm
not sure I think it's a bit potassium or
something
because then his kidneys can't filter it
out so he's got to eat special food he
hates
but I'm not sure I think the issue is
his body just isn't able to process it
properly I looked into stem cell therapy
it was told by one doctor that uh for
young cats that have congenital uh
issues with their kidneys it doesn't
work it's not that's not what it's for
it's for older cats that are have
deterioration but I'm not I'm not going
to give I was very I pretty much gave up
but now I I'm gonna push it off well I
mean it just cause many yeah what do we
got I was talking about when we brought
him to the hospital the first time they
said A week maybe and so it's been a
couple weeks and he's walking around
he's yelling he's doing cat stuff you
know he's jumping up he's jumping he
won't play anymore I tried dangling the
core in front of him he just stares at
it he goes into hiding so I don't know
how much time he's got left man how old
is he four four he's a burrowing cat too
he's always loved the burrow so he's he
they say he's got undeveloped kidneys
and he's got a heart valve defect likely
because when you know his street cat his
mom was eating garbage then he was born
he ate garbage
and we gave him a good life as long as
we could
see about the stem cells man yeah we'll
see if we can uh bring him back clone
him says Steph and Lucio well the idea
we had was that we were going to get
another cat
um before he passes so that he can teach
the other cat how to be a cat and then
he'll we'll carry on his legacy but you
see eunuch so he can't have kids himself
you were saying they don't do well cats
don't do well with new cats they don't
stresses them out you have to take the
two cats and then put them close the
door and have them sniff each other and
then eventually they get used to it
otherwise they fight but maybe if we get
a baby
you know baby kitten or whatever he
might he might be chill you know he he
likes other cats he's chill all right
ossery says you're wrong this time Tim
there are four parties sickle donkey
elephant and lion don't look at me Ian's
the one who said there were three
parties you know what I would take a
fourth party even if it was a Communist
party I'd rather have more parties the
better it's one party it's always been
one party
I suppose suppose
Let's uh what do we got let's grab some
super chits
Grim wolf says an NFL player died in the
field back in the 70s and they still
finished the game yeah who was that you
mentioned them right yeah let me see if
I can pull that up again Dan something I
think you said
Jeremiah says Occam's razor probably
steroids
for real why not yeah right
that guy's awesome too don't they test
for steroids I think they do randomly
I might have already canceled this guy
in 19 it was 1971 that the guy died on
the field uh yeah Chuck Hughes
Chuck Hughes how did he die
what does it say what are the secrets
where are we at
little sausage says as a Canadian
veteran we can't get mental health care
I desperately need it jbp helped me
immensely I am likely to get mated now
because I can't get care Canadian Health
Care equals Death care said to hear a
man you gotta just watch some more jbp
man
put put Peterson on on Loop
it'll help you out he's not the only one
there was a really funny post that said
to all the disaffected young white men
who are listening to Andrew Tate here's
a better here's a better uh show for you
and it was Jocko willing and I'm like
yeah maybe
I don't know
uh Taco's cool dude so maybe that is I
also like uh Joe Rogan promoted this guy
was it t-mask Inc or something like that
I followed him on Instagram I don't but
I just he he's he's really good at
shooting guns crazy good I was watching
him shoot a handgun at like 100 yards or
something and he's like perfect accuracy
every time I'm like that dude's that's
legit I got some data as you could
follow Chuck Hughes was 28 year old wide
receiver for the Lions Detroit Lions and
he collapsed on the field and died to a
heart attack later uh there were only 62
seconds left in that game so they played
him out maybe they would have canceled
it if it was early in the game he had a
heart attack on the field yeah oh yeah
this was this is first quarter second
quarter last night right right a lot of
games it was very early on that's crazy
man I don't know maybe maybe it was the
the was it called carditis or whatever
some
could have been some arterial sclerosis
heart disease no that's what the Hues
was arterial what was that that's that
thing people are mentioning comment
something what was it called did you
close it so many tabs what is it
oh I didn't I didn't say anything
commodorus
tomatillo Cordis
or commotion the commotion
Riley Lewin says Tim's Trudeau
impression is just denga cumin from
yeah is it I don't know I know I've I've
I I remember that show but I don't think
about it yeah that's that's a blast in
the past been a while Bobo Bobo Bobo
yeah is that what it is
I think
yeah I think that's right and that's
actually right yeah I have no idea all
right where we get Brian says Jordan
Peterson should accept the re-education
training request request and then on
YouTube and then on YouTube show
everyone what he's learning yeah for
real man he should definitely we want to
know what they're doing to people like
what's the reach re-education go do it
and then tell everybody what they're
doing
here we go Kyle Casimir says Canada and
Mexico are part of the USA and I'm tired
of pretending otherwise
they're definitely part of a Nexus can
yeah they're all American
yeah
all right what do we got here
essay says I'm about as happy as Tim but
the speaker vote be humiliated Kevin
Tucker wants him to concede in releasing
all the January 6 content to the public
Epic
that'd be cool
there we go
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Luke once said
to Santa saved America I agree
I agree I don't know when I said that um
I might have been talking about the the
lockdowns and going against the coveted
mandates and how Florida was viciously
attacked by the corporate media but I I
don't remember saying that exactly maybe
I did I don't know
10 second says Tim took the vaccine in
mace in May seven days later had a huge
clot go into my heart cause super
hypertension and almost killed me no
history of clots or high blood pressure
uh which which vaccine was it they've
come out outright for a while and said
AstraZeneca which is not I don't believe
it's in the United States and Johnson
and Johnson were causing blood clots but
I think they've said right now the
latest study shows a significant signal
between clotting and the Pfizer vaccine
but not direct evidence of causation
a signal what is this the Florida
Surgeon General has a has a different
perspective he does and then Denmark
also made a very important ruling that I
think is worth but but I'll clarify a
signal is
uh
they they see a correlation right there
is uh uh they did a study it was limited
I think it was only like 14 people and
they were like
they they see that some people had blood
clots those people also were vaccinated
there's a signal there but they've not
yet come to a definitive statement
believe which everyone would believe it
I'm trying to clarify for for the sake
of what they're actually trying to claim
a lot of people are saying this proves
that it does well we're not quite there
correlation correlation is not causation
yeah a lot of people falsely claim that
so the Pfizer caused it where in fact it
was just linked to
meaning there's a yeah right it's via
signals via signals and what that means
is they didn't do enough research yet
right right right right right there's
there's a difference between evidence
and proof as I like to say evidence is
you come home the cake has been smashed
it's been eaten and there's a paw print
on it and you're like that paw print is
evidence that my dog ate my cake then
you walk over and find the dog he's got
some chocolate nothing on his mouth it's
on his foot and then there's the cat
covered in chocolate for some reason you
know I don't know but then uh proof
would be you you follow the evidence and
find the dogs got cake all over his face
and you're like there it is the paw
print doesn't prove the dog ate the cake
it's evidence may or may not be the case
and proof is just subjective always
subjective and someone believes there's
enough evidence they consider proof well
I mean that's a person's opinion what
I'm saying what I'm trying to explain is
just that seeing a paw print in
chocolate cake is evidence the dog ate
the cake but it doesn't prove the dog
ate the cake finding chocolate all over
the dog's mouth with bits of cake in it
is still arguing arguable could be our
good to be not proof but I think I could
set him up evidence Beyond a reasonable
doubt that's why we have that standard
and we our founding fathers man with
smart smart dudes who's your favorite
Founding Father CJ I would say Alexander
Hamilton I'm a big Hamilton guy you know
good musical good musical I'm an Aaron
Burr guy Aaron Burr
en Burr I'm always reminded that got
milk commercial remember that one where
are the guys eating the peanut butter
sandwich and he's in the museum and then
it's like you know the next question for
the you know to win the prize who shot
Alexander Hamilton in the famous duel
and he looks around and it's got like
the the gun is on his shelf as a
painting showing it and he's like oh and
he calls he's like and then he tries to
pour milk because the peanut butter is
in his mouth that was funny classic got
milk commercial come on you guys don't
remember that I remember it yeah all
right Thomas Jefferson come on Thomas
Jefferson was legit philosophically but
like Hamilton just made Alexander
Hamilton so [ __ ] cool like what what
was it about Hamilton you like the most
the musical oh come on that's how I feel
about it you know me that's why I said
Thomas Jefferson Thomas Jefferson
philosophically love it all like
Anti-Federalists the day I die but at
the same time it's just like the musical
man when they make a musical about Tom
Jefferson I'll be a Thomas Jefferson I
haven't seen it but I but I bet I would
I would hate it who is that guy who said
Give me liberty or give me death Patrick
Henry Patrick Henry dude that was legit
did he own slaves that's kind of funny
probably right that's the funny thing
about it Give me liberty or give me
death but not those people that's the
funny contradiction of a lot of them but
you know what I can respect is the
founding fathers planted the seeds
then you you eventually end up with
Frederick Douglass who said are you
going to live by your own words and it
was kind of like you're going to be a
hypocrite or what and then they're like
oh he's kind of right yeah but it's
funny I I I did Patrick Henry have
slaves I don't know I don't know look at
us find out yeah see see if you can find
out they were founding fathers who
didn't you know and they were out like
nah it's not okay you know what I mean
did he did you find it
I haven't found it yet what are people
in the chat saying did he
I don't know I think that'd be funny uh
where are we at let's get some super
chants red pill keep it 100 says there
is a war on masculinity because you can
you cannot Empower women without we
Empower women without weakening men
I don't necessarily believe that
um you cannot Empower women by weakening
men without weakening men I don't think
that's true yeah yeah I do think that uh
what you'll see is a bell curve and and
between men and women it you'll you will
see more men on the higher end of the
bell curve than women because of the
greater male variability hypothesis
that's just about it uh yeah uh Henry
Patrick Henry apparently had a lot of
land and about 80 slaves over the course
of his life I don't know isn't that kind
of like funny yeah yeah I can respect
that that motto and then you get New
Hampshire Live Free or Die but like it's
just a hilarious contradiction that he's
like the king can't tell me what to do
now those people better do as they're
told however it says he would go on to
become aware of the wrongdoings within
celebrity and push for its abolishment
that's cool so there you go so many of
our founding fathers too it's like they
had this like moral conundrum of like
okay like this is probably not ideal I
don't believe this based on like their
fight their own individual fight for
liberty but like I don't know it's just
it's still obviously like you said it's
just weird like you're chaining Give me
liberty to give me death and but but
actually maybe maybe Ian just kind of
solved it maybe he stands up and he goes
they're like should we have Independence
and he gets angry and he goes Give me
liberty or give me death and then some
guy goes dude Patrick you have slaves
and he goes good point yeah I mean man
maybe I shouldn't yeah like maybe that
was a really like a strong Awakening for
a lot of these guys where they're like
the king's trying to tell me what I can
and can't do that's BS and then someone
else is like yeah well I mean like
slavery's happening and then they
probably went yeah damn
I mean Thomas Jefferson had slaves but
he did oppose it he's just none of these
people were morally strong enough for
the times to just outright do away with
it I get that like now with I mean we
had the slave trade in the Congo right
now I don't know if it's if there's a
trade necessarily people are slaving
away digging out Cobalt like it is an
African slave trade going on right now
in the world
um tens hundreds of thousands I don't
know how many thousands but like
I'm born into this system I don't like
it it's like I'm born I have slave I'm a
landowner my dad is landowner we have
slaves and now I have to change that
system in my lifetime yeah and I've
always said though like also too I hate
when people like apply their 2023
mindset to literally 100 years ago right
so it's like for you to be like okay
like slavery is this terrible thing yes
we do recognize that as a fact today but
they came into the world with this
expectation that they genuinely could
own other people and so yes it's
deplorable it was absolutely an evil
institution but at the same time it's
like you cannot hold the standards of
2023 to the standards of that era in
time so yo check this out we got some
super chats uh Peckerwood says Gates
sent a letter to the architect of the
Capitol questioning why McCarthy is
allowed to occupy the speaker's office
aquifan says Gates just dropped a letter
calling McCarthy a squatter for
occupying the speaker office while
coming in second place oh man that is
good um let's see if I can I can uh pull
up from Matt Gates here on Twitter so
wild if he has to literally move out of
the speaker's office like I feel like
that's yes that's a video you can outrun
he tweeted just five minutes ago I'd
like to report a squatter
okay send a letter to the architect of
the Capitol he said uh Dear Mr Blanton I
write to inform you the Speaker of the
House Office located at the US Capitol
building is currently occupied by rep
Kevin McCarthy as of this morning the
117th Congress adjourned uh how do you
pronounce that sign D Sani die Sunny die
yeah and a speaker from from the 118th
Congress has not been elected after
three undeciding votes no member can lay
claim to the office what is the basis in
law house rule or precedent to allow
someone who has placed second in three
successive speaker elections to occupy
the Speaker of the House Office how long
will he remain there before he is
considered a squatter please write back
promptly as it seems Mr McCarthy can no
longer be considered speaker designate
following today's uh balloting sincerely
Matt Gates wow man bra vote Matt Gates
that's that's epic who told McCarthy
that was a good idea I know man I saw
the video like the pictures and they're
like of them rolling this stuff then
like little I was like this talk about
an arrogant piece of garbage I I it's
I'm so happy to hear that he lost three
times especially with that he thinks
he's he's doing the Hillary thing it's
my turn now now get out of here dude our
government is not your stupid game of
hopscotch you're waiting in line to get
in it's it's it's it's a serious thing
and these people are like I've been
waiting it's my turn sorry I don't know
maybe it'll be Jim Jordan maybe it'll be
I don't know Lauren bumper who knows
don't care but it's also just really sad
like the man is lost three times and
it's like I feel like you're talking to
a girl and you DM her once and she
leaves you on red maybe you do it one
more time maybe maybe she had bad cell
service when she got that first message
but to do it three times and expect I am
going to keep dming this woman like and
no no that's her that's harassment sir
and I think that you need to like this
is what's happening here it's just it's
just embarrassing at this point you just
need to pack it up I look forward to
tomorrow it should be a lot of fun so
until then smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends and become a
member at timcast.com we're gonna have
the members only uncensored show coming
up for all you guys later on tonight
maybe in about 45 or so minutes It'll be
live at timcast.com so again go to
timcast.com click join us become a
member support our work we're building
physical locations we're going to be
launching a skate show the new the new
studio space is currently being built
it's bigger than this one there's a
massive space for recreation it's 40
feet tall it's going to be epic and
we're gonna do a lot of culture building
with your support you can follow the
show at timcast IRL you can follow me at
timcast CJ do you want to shout anything
out yeah of course well thanks for
having me Tim and you guys can keep up
with me at the CJ Pearson and also keep
up with the great work that prageru is
doing at prageru as well Hamilton we'll
talk about that and maybe in the avft CJ
thank you so much for coming on that was
great my YouTube channel is youtube.com
forward slash we are change I've been
doing a video there almost every single
day for nearly 15 years now today I did
a video about the crazy situation in the
U.S Virgin Islands all a coincidence
lots of coincidences I'm going to be
answering questions on that video right
after this one uh check it out on
youtube.com forward slash we are changed
see you there and I found a cool uh
technological breakthrough James tour
from Rice University they're working
with uh rats and one of the rats had its
sign its spine completely severed
completely unable to move and they
injected the separation or whatever you
want to call that hole with uh graphene
Nano ribbons and polyethylene glycol and
within two weeks the spine had regrown
back to like 18 out of 21 functional the
rats walking around I mean it's
completely severed spine has been
regrown and then a week later it's an
even better condition moving faster
running away
high tech we're talking healing the
crippled people that are paralyzed we'll
be able to walk again kind of thing I'm
very excited James tour is the scientist
you want to follow him on Twitter and uh
if you want to find more cool stuff like
that follow me on Twitter and anywhere
else mines YouTube anywhere else see you
later guys and I am at surge.com
everywhere nice uh good chat this is a
good one I enjoyed it good fun we will
see all of you over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out cheers